We're live, Remy Warren. What's
up buddy? Hey, how's it going? Uh,
before we get started,
let me just say,
this shirt that I'm wearing on to each
shirt is my friend Yannis patella shoes,
shirt, and a, you can get one a,
you get a 15% discount if you go to hunt
to eat.com and use the discount code
Rogan. Hey, you go? Yeah, I, they
gave me a discount code to use.
Now they give you a free
one. Well, no, I know,
but they gave me one to
put on something and I did.
And they accidentally did it wrong.
And the shirts for $2 a face.
It's a jump on now. Yeah.
What was the discount?
They fuck they'd said it like 20%
off is like $20 off an $80 shirt.
Ooh. Yeah. That had to
hurt. It's like, Oh shit.
So we were just talking about, uh, before
we, uh, got the podcast star that you,
you do yoga when you're, uh,
not on the road when you're,
that's my workout of choice. I feel like
if I'm gonna, if I'm going to work out,
it's good. It's a good stretch.
Keeps, keeps me limber.
Plus you're surrounded by hot chicks
that are sweating and it's like not a bad
deal. So I'm going to the
wrong class. My classes,
a housewives or just trying to barely
keep it together. Oh No, not where I go.
Yeah.
It's probably better where I go.
There's always that one dude with the
lower back tattoo with his mat right in
front of me and I'm just thinking,
damn, is it a weird like for a guy,
a lower back tattoo is a
real no, no. Yeah. I wonder,
but maybe he got it before
it was a no, no. Is that
possible? When did that happen?
Right when it came,
he was like in line and then he got it
and then he walked out and they're like,
yeah, there's certain spots. It's weird,
right? It's like certain spots where like,
like you could tattoo your arms, but if
you get up into your neck, people go,
yeah, rough childhood. As soon as
you get to your face or girls, all,
Jesus, what the fuck you
doing? Yeah, there's, there's
certain zones that are okay.
Like hands, you start doing your
hands are very hardcore. Yeah.
The lower back is okay.
If it's incorporated into everything
else on your body to be like one of those
Japanese Yakuza style body
bodysuit things. Yeah.
It has to and you have to
work out everything else
before you get to the lower
back. Can't start with the lower
back. But it's weird though.
Like what the tramp stamp. Like how did
that happen? Like why did, why was it,
is it just because of that's what you look
at when you're having sex doggy style.
Like you look at that spot.
What is it?
I think it was so you could,
you could see it like the low rep,
low rider pants and the crop
top shirt. Oh right. You know,
hey, she's a hoe. She's makes mistakes.
She's impulsive. Yeah. That's another
thing. Dudes are not allowed to do it.
You can have no shirt on but you
can't have a half shirt. No. You know,
or, or like you can have shorts or long
pants, but capris you don't create,
those are up the knees. The
calves the half. That's so true.
You can't have, you can't have, it's a no
go. That's a definite no go. How's that?
It's weird like the,
no, the no shirts. Okay.
Like if you're at the beach
and you have no shirt,
but if you had a jog bra type set up,
not happening baby,
you can't do it.
Well you'd have to custom make it and
then that's just awkward in itself. Right?
Like why did you cut the
bottom of your shirt off?
You can cut the sleeves off my
belly to be free, Bro. Yeah.
I like it to be free and we have weird
choices when it comes to that. Like I do,
I fucking still to this day take
more shit for wearing a fanny pack.
I notice was that was
like leather fanny pack.
That's next level shit.
Fucking strong.
I learned about it from dice clay dice
clay was in here and he had this very
strong fan. Oh what is this you're
showing us here. That's real.
Is that it says kid Cuddy wore
a crop top to Coachella. No,
he did. He did. He really did. Kid
cutting. Where that he was in the podcast.
He didn't seem gay. Well there
he is. Look at that. Hmm.
What the fuck ever take your
shirt off son. There's rules.
There's rules in this life. Well I guess
maybe if you got that nice to haves.
Yeah, that's no good. It's that backpack
one up there. That one would the uh,
that we were just showing
this one for folks listening.
This is fucking completely ridiculous
because it's a sweat shirt,
like a big puffy sweatshirt,
but it's been cut at the midriff
like right where the lower rib is.
That's where it's cut. I
just, I don't think I'll ever
get into that fashion. Sure.
Now, yeah, that's,
there's someone saying something that
I don't know what he said, but I don't,
I don't want to hear it. Whatever
that guy's saying. It's weird.
It's weird rules. You know
when, when I've gone hunting,
people have given me shit for having
two different kinds of clothes.
Like you have like a COO, you shirt on
and Sitka pants. Like, okay, I'm, I'm the,
I've always,
my whole life been the opposite of that.
I would just mix and match so
I'm not wearing like the hated,
when I called it like the pajamas,
like you look like you're wearing a one z.
Like I'll use the same company maybe,
but a couple of different shades. Yeah.
Top and bottom. The hunting thing is
a bit of a fashion thing, you know,
it is like there's,
there's,
it's weird because it's like one of the
few times where men will comment on each
other's fashion, you know, like
men, men, they'll go, hey man,
those are a nice blue jeans, bro. Let
me, I like the cut. Who's making those?
Like you're staring at my Dick,
something's going on. Well, it's like,
it's acceptable to,
for men to wear a $500 pair of pants
when they're hunting pants. Yeah.
What is that? Right. But
there's like, there's a fashion
east, that thing going on,
you know,
and I think a lot of the
camouflage isn't even for animals.
Eyesight is for humans. Totally
freaky Yolanda, this stuff,
they've done so many studies on
camouflage, you know? And that's, uh,
I actually did this thing
for apex. We're looking into
camouflage and it's just crazy.
It's one of those things like we
have a lot to learn about camouflage,
but we already see what can they say? What
can animals see? They vary, right? Yeah,
yeah. Let's take some shitty
eyesight, right? Yeah.
But so like the way
camouflage works is there,
there's like matching where you're
kind of just matching the environment,
maybe one shade of like sand colored
bottom and then there's like modeled where
its spot as rock type shape and then
there's disruptive where it essentially
breaks up the outline of whatever it is.
So it doesn't look like what it is.
And disruptive I think,
in my opinion is probably
the most effective camouflage
when you like start to
really analyze it,
is that this disruptive,
like firstlight has this
kind that's like dark stripe,
light stripe and it doesn't box.
Yeah. And so sometimes you're like,
it's like you look at it and it
doesn't really look like if it doesn't,
if camouflage he doesn't look
like anything, then that's
the best I would say. So.
And so is the idea that it
breaks up the shape of a human,
like different ones with
the animals. Yeah, exactly.
They see the shape of a human go that's
done. Yeah. I did this thing, uh,
it was a friend of mine is
a army sniper and so forth.
Apex episode did a,
made a Ghillie suit.
Crazy. Like it was cool. Like a legit one,
not one of those like goofy
and looked like the swamp.
We still look like the swamp thing but
were you would just like veg up and match
your exact surroundings
and I'm not kidding you.
We took a picture where he was
like standing there and three,
four feet away you just disappear. Do
you have the picture? Uh, if you have it.
So I'm going to email to Jamie if you
have it and I'll put on the screen and
I'll see you again. They say that Turkeys
have like really, really good eyesight,
right? Yeah. Like when I wore
like a mask, a Ghillie suit mask,
like a shitty one. Yeah. You know when
we went Turkey hunting is, but it was,
you know, just like just see out
with a slit. But it was cool.
It's cool to wear it. I felt
like I was really hiding. Yeah,
I'm invisible but they can't see like,
you know,
like you have like those real tree
cammo prints that look just like leaves,
like deers, can't see that.
And then I think, you know,
I mean in my opinion it just turns
to black once you get it to a certain
distance.
So some of some camouflage is just really
like based on how far away from your
pray you might be. Cause like
that kind of stuff. You know,
he's made for tree stand and it looks
cool and grew up in the tree in there.
You could probably wear blaze orange
pumpkin suit and they wouldn't see you
anyways. Right. You're
still high. Yeah. That's uh,
yeah.
I mean then you get out of distance
and it just looks black or dark.
So it doesn't really,
I wouldn't think it'd be effective
for like what I do out west or in the
mountains and things like that.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of weird things that
I'm starting to notice cause obviously I
haven't been hunting for that long.
There's a bunch of weird fetishes.
The clothes fetish is one of them.
There's a, there's a boot fetish for sure.
The questions I get asked all,
it's like always hold on up to this
microphone secret. Super Directional. Yep.
Is that better? Yeah. I just
leaning, leaning like a Cholo or, um,
yeah, the things I get asked
the most boots in Cammo pattern.
It's, that's it. Well people
get into it, you know,
they think about it before they're doing
it and so it becomes something like
they want to look the part.
It's like guys want him wearing Nike
sneakers and the right shorts when they go
play pickup basketball.
It's kind of the same thing.
I always get a rifle hunters like
come out on El. So they're like,
well this camouflage match,
we're, we're hunting.
And my answer is you have a
rifle. Like if, if they see,
if they see the shirt underneath
your jacket, you're already screwed.
So we don't necessarily need to worry
about it. But I mean, that being said,
I do wear camouflage, meaning for people
don't understand what we're saying.
When you rifle hunt, you're really far
away. Whereas if your bow hunting and elk,
you would be proud of you like to
be within 50 yards. Yeah, exactly.
What's like the longest shot you've
ever taken on an elk with a archery?
Oh, probably wouldn't be an elk.
Could be a deer. Um, about 80 yards.
But that's a long ways. That's
not typical. Like everything
was perfect, you know?
Yeah. That's a tricky thing,
right? With archery learning when,
when you can pull something like that
off. Yeah, exactly. Because the thing is,
you know, I think a lot of people
too, like a lot of hunters,
they've got like this debate on what's
ethical for distance. Other things.
I think it just depends on the
situation cause there's, I,
I've taken a few animals that what I
would consider like the edge of ethical
range,
but yet I've never lost one.
But the only animal that I've ever not
recovered was like 30 yards, you know?
So anything can go wrong
at any distance is just,
I think it's one of those things, cause
I think when you take it further shot,
you know,
your banking on your,
you're paying maybe more attention
to all the exact, you know,
and not just getting like all it's close,
it's going to happen.
Is that one of the biggest
issues that you have when,
cause I know you take out like
really new hunters sometimes. Yeah.
Like one of the bigger issues must
be having them make a correct shot.
Yeah.
That that is,
that's the hard part because
I think if you're new hunter,
you may not expect the reactions that
you're going to have in the moment.
You can shoot at the range all you want.
You can do all this other stuff,
but you can't factor in that emotion of
when you're about to take an animal's
life. And that's, that's something
you can't practice. You know,
it's just that. And so yeah.
So that part of like I,
if I'm with someone, I try to keep them
calm and just, cause if, if you're,
if somebody that's with you is
just like, Oh, a gag, hurry up,
then you're going to be panicked and you,
you're going to just
not make a good shot. Whereas
if the person like, okay,
you know, take your time.
Like just real calm and mellow.
Do you know of anybody that's ever
used Beta blockers, Beta blockers,
Beta blockers or something
that performers use?
I've never experimented with them but uh,
recently got a prescription because
I just want to see what the deal is.
I'm trying to figure out when would
be a good time to try it. I would,
I would think like archery elk would be
like the perfect time to try it because
your heart rate is just jacked.
Your adrenaline is flying and your
nerves are crackling. Like, uh,
I think archery,
elk hunting probably the most nervous
I've ever been next to like martial arts
competition.
Like right up there,
right at the edge of like martial
arts competition is like, it gets,
it gets to this point where people
go into shock. Like just, it's just,
you see it even in the UFC sometimes you
see like guys just can't perform right.
They just kid, they're, they're
overwhelmed by, by the, uh,
the moment, the, the, the,
the nerves, the adrenaline dump,
the whole thing that is raw.
And the guys who were just heroes and
the gym, they get on those bright lights,
they can't do it.
I think archery,
elk hunting is probably the closest you
can get to martial arts competition that
I've experienced. And I
was wondering like, man,
I bet if you took a Beta blocker that
would probably alleviate a lot of that.
It could, does it last for a long period
of time. Cause you never know when them,
it's like, yeah, you take it in the
morning and you're just kind of like,
what does it tell you out?
Oh okay.
Apparently what it does is it
blocks the reaction. I should have.
Like Mark Gordon explained
it to me and Dr. Gordon,
who's a buddy of mine has been on the
podcast a bunch of times who told me about
it,
but like I watched this
television show and it was on um,
nerves and on,
um,
reactions to stress and pressure and
they had these, a concert, um, uh,
performers like classical music
performers and they would talk about how
difficult it is to perform in front of
live audiences and they discovered Beta
blockers. And then the guy
was saying like, it just
changed my life. He said, no,
I take a Beta blocker and I can perform
easily the way I perform in the studio
when we're practicing in
front of thousands of people.
It's no problem at all.
Yeah. I've noticed that,
that, that excitement level
just cloud your thinking too.
And that's what in hunting you don't
anticipate because all of a sudden you're
now doing things with clouded judgment.
And I guarantee like
animals can feel that,
that tension, I don't know what
it is or what they're feeling,
but if you are just out there observing
an animal or don't really care,
don't get that excited. It's
almost like some people go, oh,
how did right before I was going
to shoot it ran off. You know,
it's because of that. Just like as that
excitement level grows and you freak out,
I feel like they sense that energy.
They've got a different way
of feeling their environment.
I mean fish especially do that.
They can feel like when I was
spear phishing and you dive down,
you would consciously try to lower
your heart rate and the fish would swim
towards you.
What is your freaked out official will
not come near you or they'll even swim
away.
So you go down there and you just have
to like essentially zen out and then the
fish swim up to you and the
jab them. Yup. Like Sushi.
I, whoa. I wonder, I mean we're,
we just assume that animals have all the
same sets of skills or the same sets of
senses that we do.
But fish have a bunch of weird things
like that lateral line across their body
which detects movement and they can get
other things from that. Right. What else?
Well it's essentially detecting
vibrations in the water. Yes.
So it's anything from heart
rates to fish swimming,
other animals moving in the water.
They can detect heart rates.
Would that lateral line?
Wow.
The line with what that means
for people don't understand.
What I'm saying is there is a,
if you go from a fish's gills and draw
a straight line back to their tail,
there's actually a line there and that
line is just solid like nerve endings.
Right?
Sensitive nerve endings.
It pick up things that we can't detect
in the water and also the senses of smell
like can you imagine what a fucking
elk sense of smell must be like?
They probably can smell things that
we don't even think smell like fear.
Like they probably can smell it.
You pronounce or sweating a
little more and fuck. Yeah. Yeah.
A lot of predators when they
go into that final stock mood,
their heart rates slow down.
Really? Yeah. Oh that makes sense.
Cause like when you see a cat on
a cat's about the bus to move,
they start moving really slow and then
they fucking done the mad mad dash.
Yeah.
It's like the lulling their prey into a
false sense of contentment and security.
They're cool to watch. We did a, we
did an apex episode and we were like,
well it's, explain what that means.
You have a show called Apex Predator.
It's fucking great show. And it's on
sportsmans channel toward channel.
They're the same.
They're owned by the same people,
which is a fucking pain in the ass now
because that is removed from Viacom.
They work that shit out yet. I
don't know. Yeah, there was a,
um, there was a website that
you could go to. What was it?
Keep my outdoor TV or something
like that. Jamie. I think
Verizon, Verizon. Um, I guess, uh,
what is it?
Fiber optic Fido's they,
they pulled all of the hunting channels
and then like, yeah, that's what it is.
So what is the, um, keep,
keep my outdoor tv.com.
You can, uh, go there
and it'll show you, look,
it's telling you to drop Verizon
switched providers today. I can, oh,
this is that. So how does, how do you, is
that like a satellite thing or what's it,
Verizon is a fiber optic line and it's a,
I believe it's done like the Internet,
you,
you get a,
it's Verizon files cause
they have a Verizon fiber
optic Internet service. And for
whatever reason, I don't know.
I don't know what it was,
whether it's some sort of a,
a deal that they couldn't make or whether
they're actually trying to force out.
That's what people are worried about,
that they're forcing out hunting and
fishing shows and they're just removing
them because they, they don't like
it or they think it's distasteful.
Or maybe someone at the very top is a,
uh,
animal rights person. Well, I
dunno, I dunno. I really don't know.
But that would suck if you really
enjoyed watching those shows, which I do.
And you a, all of a sudden Verizon
says, oh well this isn't on, but hey,
you can watch some fucking
fake reality show on, you know,
people that fake live in the
woods on the discovery chat.
Cause that's what they're recommending.
Like when people go, yeah,
when people are going to that,
they're actually recommending
these rigged shows, which,
you know, some of them are fun, like
life below zero. That's, but that's,
those are real events. Like you watch that
show, they don't have to fake anything.
There's those fucking people a really
live in 200 miles above the arctic circle.
So as soon as state, if they're
like, you really liked a meat eater,
but instead you can watch Alaska,
Yukon bear country, gold survival,
pawn shop.
You just said that.
But that's going to be a show now.
Someone's listening going Quick Rock Climb
Down Jab has to go into the Yukon and
find some gold while he shoots a moose
for survival to selling his dad's punk
job. And at the end of the
show, it's a cooking contest.
They have a barbecue off and
Kanye West is just a fierce dude.
I watched one of those barbecue shows.
I was hooked instantly. I was like,
how the fuck am I going to
get hooked by a barbecue show?
Just a bunch of guys barbecuing. I'm
like, this is going to be boring.
They're not going to get
me. Meanwhile, they got me.
I was there for the whole episode.
The next one.
That was one of those back to back deals
where they showed like two or three
episodes in a row.
I watched three of those fucking things.
Three fucking shows where guys are
trying to make the perfect brisket,
but there's no secrets given out.
I'm sure.
Oh you you're no better of a barbecuer?
No.
Well you know the best way
to do it is pellet grills.
That's what one thing I
realized. Really? Yeah.
I'll a lot of those big time barbecue
competitions, these pellet grills now,
because pellet grills,
if you don't know what I'm talking about,
pellet grills use a real hardwood,
but say if you buy a table like this and
they have to saw it when they saw it,
they take the saw dust. Either
use one pellet grill. No,
I've got like a pellet stove.
But is it the same thing? No,
it was like a fireplace but it
uses like compacted pellets. Yeah,
we're real similar. They use
these, uh, it looks like, um,
like a little cylinder, a little tiny
cylinders that are compressed, saw,
saw dust and the natural sugars in
the wood is the only thing that keeps
together. Like if you take it with your
fingers, you can break it up and it,
there's a hopper, like a big, um,
like a big metal box and underneath the
hoppers a worm drive and it spins and it
feeds it to an element.
And the element,
there's like a cup and then
there's an element and the, the,
the pellets drop into the cup and
the element is below the cups.
So the element heats it and starts
a fire and it keeps it at a steady
temperature, like plus or minus one
or two degrees. It's really good.
And like a bucket of the hopper,
which is filled, like say, look,
it looks like maybe a five or 10 10
gallon bucket will last for days.
It's amazingly efficient. I
have a Yoder, but uh, they,
they have a green mountain
grills when I had to.
It's just really good and they're fairly
inexpensive and you can barbecue on
those things. Slow Cook and that's
what it looks like. See that hopper,
like a pellet stove or whatever.
But so you see how it works there
with the warm drive where I'm drives,
feeds it into the fire and then
it's slowly cooks. That's cool.
Ah Dude. It's like cooking on wood but
you don't have to deal with wood. Exactly.
It's all wood.
It's does no chemicals whatsoever.
And you get that smoky taste to the
meat too. It's really nice. I grill on,
I have a Yoder that I really
like because it has a,
an option for direct heat where you
crank it up and the fire gets really high
and then you put those grill grates
down. Like I remove this, uh,
it's like heat diffusion plate. It's
like, uh, you know, for like slow cooking.
You take that out and then the fire
goes right under the grill grades.
It's amazing for steaks for, for anything.
That's awesome. Yeah. That's great. Yeah.
Cause I, I love cooking
over wood. I've got,
except I've got like three cords of woods
stack down the cabin. I'll do you. Yeah.
Do you do it rich? Do
you do so like, like uh,
like smoking with like a real smoker or
you have to feed the logs and make sure
the temperature stays down the smoker?
I do the, you know, glass door,
easy thermometer on it. Oh yeah.
Forget it. George Foreman stuff.
George form and style. Do they have a
George Foreman smoker? I don't know.
They should. They will know. Yeah. I
had one that I used that was like, um,
what does that one company that makes
a lot of like smoking a hunting style
stuff and they make a vacuum
cu? Yes. Western. Yeah.
I had a western smoker. We had to
add wood chips to it. It was kind of,
it was fairly like self
throw him in the bottom and turn it on.
That was okay.
But once I started fucking around
with that Green Mountain Grill,
I gave up on that completely. Just
like, oh, this is so much easier.
And it's just as good, like, look,
it wasn't like there was any
benefit to doing it the other way,
but I think there is something about
a real wood smoke or like when I watch
those barbecue competition.
Yeah,
there's something about figuring out
how much to open up that little door to
make the air go in just enough to keep
that temperature steady and they're
checking out. There's something
that like men do with fire.
There's like some weird thing like, like
if you're out, like if you're at a fire,
like a camp fire and you're hanging
around with a bunch of people,
like a guy who could make a
fire good like you, like Ah,
you fucking nailed it later.
That has a good fire and you're all
sitting around and it's like there's
something about men and fire
that just goes right to your DNA.
Oh yeah.
I always say,
because I do a lot of hunting alone
and you might be in like random.
I was in Africa one time
just by myself and it was,
you hear these noises even never heard
before and as soon as you get that fire
going, it's just a comforting,
it's a comforting feeling.
I think. It's just like,
it's a primal thing that,
you know, if you have a fire,
you're going to survive through the night,
whether it's cold or
whatever that fire is,
is just our safety system most likely.
And you see it and you're like, Ugh,
I feel more comfortable. Yeah, that's good
Rinella. Uh, when he was here, he was
here a couple of weeks ago and uh,
as he was here,
he got a text from his friend that
they had just taken this kid out. Like,
I think he's 18 years old. Yeah. On his
first hunt ever while he's in a tent,
he gets attacked by a 500
pound predatory black bear.
He wakes up to this bear biting
his head. His friend, he's scream,
his friend rushes in, shoots the
bear, but it goes through the barons,
shatters his elbow,
so he gets shot in the fucking elbow.
The bear runs out of that 10 into
another 10 where this other guy shoots it
three times with a shotgun and then
kills it. Wow. Where was this at?
Alaska first ever black bear.
Yeah.
First ever hunt is kids on and he wakes
up his head getting eaten by a 500 pound
black bear. That's a bad
day. Fucking black bear too,
that you know, you gotta you
gotta you know, like a man.
I hope I don't get bit by
a spider tonight. Injury.
It's a bear. Is Camping.
Stuff's pretty cool. We're out
here in nature getting one.
So biting your fucking head.
Ow. We, that's got to suck.
I guess his head was like near the door.
I mean that's the only
thing I could think of.
His head was like near the door and he
left the, it'll get a little air in here,
lip with the vestibule opened or whatever.
You know, it's dope. I never used one,
but I think I would love it
is, um, you ever seen those uh,
campers that they have on top of
your roof? Like a tab that opened?
Do you have one of those?
No,
I've got my truck set up with the camper
shell and then I've got a shelf in
there and I get it all
set up for traveling.
You use a Toyota land cruisers
that what you use? Um, in,
in New Zealand I use it at Toyota,
but uh, here I've got a full,
like a Ford f one 50. And if you
turn completely set it up just for,
for hunting and you can you sleep in it?
Yeah, I sleep, I can sleep in the back.
So when I'm on the road I've got
like, uh, I've got the side open up,
it's like a camper shell on it and then
the side lifts up and I got a shelf in
there,
was getting aggressive,
embarrassed,
got a,
got a shelf in there so I can kind of
sleep underneath and keep stuff up top.
And then, and then I've got roof
rack and the whole deal. Yeah,
because when I first found out about you
was from that show solo hunter and you
went on these cool adventures, I was
like, wow, that must be fucking fun to do.
So much because you're doing these,
these crazy hunts while you're
backpacking out, deep, deep,
deep into the woods by yourself.
And there's this real element of danger
to doing that because if you fall snap,
uh, an ankle or something like that, like,
man, there's no one to call does you?
Gotta you gotta get out of there on your
own. No one's going to find you. Right?
Like I remember that there was one episode
where you slept inside this ancient
Indian structures,
ancient nature,
native American structure that you
found in Nevada. And I was like,
dad has gotta be one of the fucking
coolest things you could ever do.
It was pretty cool. You know, you
find, I find all kinds of cool places.
There's a place in New Zealand and I
like to go now that I found it's just a
rock and crawl under and sleep,
then you don't have to bring a tent.
You just got your sleeping
bag. That's your spot. You
Go, yeah, I like to go light.
So I try to minimize the amount of things
that I have to bring. Um, because, um,
well for filming it, I'm
carrying so much shit. Yeah.
Two cameras and tripods and batteries and
by the time I add the essential stuff,
I'm like way over weight. Now when you do
that, when you do this and this show, uh,
this is a different show. It's
called Solo Hunter. When you do that,
you film everything. You film all,
you filmed the setup, you film the,
the actual shot.
You film yourself drawing back,
you fill them all this different stuff.
Who Puts it all together?
You send it to Tim and Tim. Tim Burton it,
he puts it together. Do you call him up?
And he's like, dude, you're editing sucks.
You missed it. My, my favorite course up.
Uh,
yeah,
actually I do a picture of me looking
at whimsical out of the mountain an hour
getting that shot when I walked
for ridges over is four miles away.
I used my entire battery. And you didn't
use it. Do you give him notes? Like,
like what I try to, yeah, we,
we just kinda fly by the seat of our pants
on that one sometimes. I mean it's uh,
yeah,
it was just kind of give him the footage.
She sits down and watches everything,
which some of it is just ridiculous.
I think if he put together a montage of
just the ridiculous shit that I've said
films and he's like,
why did you do that?
This is one of my all time favorite shows.
One of the reason why is when
you're solo out there, you, you,
there's a sense that you, you get like
that. Um, I feel like I'm with you.
Yeah. You know what I mean?
Like if you go hunting,
like if say if I'm on meat or something
like that, maybe it's because I know,
but it's like your v really aware that
Steve has a crew is a production crew.
There's PA's, there's guys that are
carrying stuff, there's interns, there's,
you know,
like when we would go hunt,
they would be like two guys with cameras
that would be following us around. Yeah.
That's the thing. Like when I'm by I, I
run,
the other thing I do is I
try to do everything like
what I call like live spine
livestream.
So if it's more important for me to
get the footage of what's going on,
then actually have things work
out I guess be successful.
And so,
I mean I've got two cameras and I tried
to set things up and it's really tough
but it's so much, it's like you're
right there because there's no filter.
You see everything that's going on.
Like you might see a camera and a shot
and you might see this other stuff,
but it's all like that's what it's like
to be out there by yourself. I guess
it's,
there's this weird feeling of connection
to nature that you get on your show
that I,
I don't think you get that in that depth
on other shows because I know you're by
herself.
Like I feel like this sort of element of
solitude and kind of danger when you're,
when you're, you're talking to the camera,
you just talking to yourself. Yeah.
And there's nobody there.
Tragic figure out how to sneak up on some
big bedded meal deer and you're trying
to put it all together and at
the same time you're filming it,
which has got to make it like twice.
Oh yeah, let's now it's like, I think
it's kind of one of those things.
You hear a hunters that are maybe rifle
hunting and they get into bow hunting
because of the challenge or whatever.
And then once I started filming things,
I thought this is the challenge. Like
that's, it's so unbelievably hard,
but it's,
for me it's exciting and fun and it's
a new element to add to the hunt.
Now. It's almost hard not to
like if I go out by myself,
even if I know I'm not going to use
it for solo hunters or whatever,
I still film it myself. I don't
know why. I always felt I do.
You're like a porn star, work
home with them. I mean, I,
there was 100 I did recently and
trying to get away from it just be,
just hunt more like I used
to. But um, I don't know.
There's that element of feel like you
almost cheated it cause he didn't capture
it or yeah, you just, it
became too, it not too easy,
but it's like I could have you would go
back and think I could have filmed that.
You know what I saw recently?
Fuze has a stabilizer that you
put on your bow that is a camera.
Yeah. Have you ever used
one of those? No. Um,
some of the places I hunt it's illegal
to have electronic devices attached to
the bow and, and for like, um,
I just refrain from putting
electronic equipment on my bow. Even.
I won't even put the Gopro,
like when I'm,
I might get a shot or two with the Gopro
on a boat depending on where I'm at.
But, uh, so it would be illegal
to have a Gopro on the bulb,
but you could probably have it on your
head like tracker here some places
because it's not an, it's not
like an electronic Aina, a site.
I think a lot of states have rewritten
the definition because people wanted to
put cameras and things on their
equipment, but you know, I dunno.
So would the,
the idea was that archery supposed
to be more difficult in any sort of
electronic gadget that you would
add that would make it easier,
would be an unfair advantage
and it wouldn't make archery
season a little easier.
And archery season is supposed
to be tougher. Is that
the idea behind thing? So,
yeah. Well they would need to do
is to stop this crossbow shit.
Like you can't see using a
crossbow during archery season.
There's tills a two totally
different things. Yeah.
That's a recent more recent development.
Um, I might as well be a rifle.
Yeah. I mean it's a short range
rifle. I mean, you have a scope,
you could be arrested on something. I
mean, you could rest it on a tripod. Yeah.
Like a rifle like that.
To be honest though,
I think most compound bows are a lot
more accurate and better than crossbows.
Really the ones that I've shot.
Yeah. That's interesting. Well,
maybe it's because you're a really
good shot too. No, I mean I've,
I've taken guys out that it's,
I've never hunted with a crossbow,
but not that I have anything against him,
but I feel like they just weren't
as effective as a regular bow. Hmm.
Do you not watch the walking
dead? Oh, well in that case,
when you're hunting zone,
zombies and elk are completely
different for sure. A crossbow,
you know, it drives me nuts about
watching that on that show. I'm like,
how is he not getting past throws?
He's shooting these mushy Zombie heads
and he could pull the Arrow out every
time. Like that shit should be blowing
right to that machine. My question is,
how does the load, have you ever
tried pulling a crossbow back?
They're like 300 pound poll and
your fingers and get caught,
so you need a special device
to drive across devices.
I think that would slow you down and
killing zombies. I think you're right.
It would be very, well I, they
never reloads on the fucking show.
It's just always loaded. It's an
automatic crossbow, in which case,
superior weapon of choice.
I've seen one of them that
I saw recently had a, uh,
it had like these handles built into it
while you pull the handles out there on
like draw strings and then you hook the
handles to the cord, the string that you,
and then you pull it back with that
and then latch, latch it in place.
But I was like, why would I do this? This
is not as good as a bow. And I was like,
well, not only that, I could put
another arrow in a bow, like, um,
when I shot my elk, I shot
it, I hit it once and then it,
it didn't know what happened.
It blew right through it.
It didn't even know we were there and
it was like, what the fuck is going on?
And within five seconds I had another
arrow on it. If it was a crossbow,
I would have been like, hold up, I
gotta get out. Get your crank out. Yeah,
those are cool. Like those old
ones that they used to have.
When you see like when they first invented
them and there was like a stick that
was like a lever that was holding it
back and it worked on this sort of a
locking mechanism and tunc and they
would shoot these bolts like in game of
Thrones style, like those type of, yeah,
crossbows but even them that's
slower and slower than a regular.
I don't see him as if,
if you've ever tried to carry you,
it's not made for caring walking around.
But it's the most awkward
thing to carry on the planet.
Think of a gun that's got like a bow
going the opposite direction, you know,
it makes a giant, it's big too. Yeah,
it's a big t e there's no effective way
to carry it. I think it's just, I dunno,
I dunno
do
he goes with me. Wow. Wow.
How long before someone makes a crossbow
that a is an homage to Jesus or it's a
big cross, an actual cross
cross bow in about, yeah,
so you could like he could,
after you've seen animal,
you can put it in the ground and go
through the motions and there is,
there was one crop they've
got the crossbows can get
the most interesting names
too because there was one
crossbow is called the penetrate
and then I can't buddy,
uh, me and my brother,
a friend of ours is a photographer
and he needed some models to me and my
brother went out and so my brother was
like the face of the zone. We were like,
oh man.
Hopefully it's the penetrator
he needed models first crossbow because
no one wanted to be the face of the
penetrating.
The penetrator were fucking stupid
name. Yeah. They have to have new, well,
every time Bose come out, every year,
like Hoyt just came out with their new,
a 2016 line of bows and they have
to come up with new names, you know,
but after a while you run on a fucking
verbs, you run on the adjectives,
you want to run out of letters to
combine together. Like, you know,
what's a night drum? Nitrogen is
white night trim. What is that? I,
it's gotta be something awesome.
They're good.
Why don't they just call it the 2016
you know, that's not a bad, yeah,
just like a truck. He'd seen me
same model, just different year
50 2016 F150 there's no confusion there.
It's not the 2016 penetrator no,
I went to dominator compound bows.
Making compound bows is, you think it's
just like a bow? It's like a simple,
I dunno,
like a simple device.
Yet the amount of engineering that goes
into these bows is crazy. I went to this,
this deal.
A G five is like an archery company
and they also make these prime bows.
And I was,
I was talking,
one of the engineers was kind of going
over like what it takes to build about
and apparently you really can't build
two bows that are identical that shoot
identical. Really? Yeah.
Because the tolerances would have to
be so minute and so kind of everybody's
goal I think is to just build two bows
that are exact but they all the way,
because things are constantly moving,
the limbs are flexing and the risers
are moving and everything is just,
so it's,
there's such a science behind
a simple tool like a a bow,
but when you start putting wheels and
cams and all kinds of things on it,
just the amount of engineering
that goes into, it's insane.
Yeah.
Well the people say that it'll change
based on what kind of strings you use.
Like if we switched to
winner's choice strings,
it's not like a real high
tolerance Strang and you know,
some people prefer the strings that it
comes with and guys we'll switch back and
forth and adjust their draw length by a
quarter of an inch at a time and monkey
around with geek out on that stuff
if you really want. So. Right.
I always just kind of uh,
get it how I like and
leave it alone. Yeah. Do you get a new bow
every year? I do. Yeah. That's the ice.
The problem, the worst. Well it's
so different than rifles. It is.
You get used to it.
It's something new.
If you have a 10 year old rifle that
things perfect. I've got, you can name it.
Yeah.
Betsy [inaudible] Hannah's bad rifle.
You know the night drums
out the new ones in,
you know like fuck because new Bose come
out every year and they'll just have
like just a little bit more power,
just a little bit more speed.
It's a little bit more of this,
a little bit more.
It's like I can't imagine
needing in some ways you know,
cause like,
like think of like a guy like Cam Haines
who kills like everything with a bow.
I mean he killed this year he killed I
think three elk or a moose to deer to
grizzly bears to grizzly bears to
two black bears all with a bow. Wow.
All at the same bow. I mean
Devo obviously works. Yeah.
Like you don't need a new boat dude.
But the new ones come out. Pam,
you got to get a new one and know he's
sponsored by Hoyt so they send them the
new one right away and he's got to get
it tuned in and got to put the new site
on. All of this new one is the thing.
This new one is that with that,
what's wrong with the old one? Do you
be killed? Everything with that old one,
but it's these extra few feet per second
that you can get with the new one. Yeah.
The extra, like the extra forgiveness
of the accuracy of the bow.
Like where it's a people who have never
shot like a compound bow have no idea.
Like how fun it is.
Like just shooting targets is
so like it's relaxing, it's fun.
It's a fun thing to do because you can't
be thinking about anything else. Yes,
exactly.
I've noticed like if I'm out there and
I'm thinking about a lot of things,
when you think about things,
your eyes drift, you know,
they always say when somebody is lying,
their eyes move up into
the right or whatever.
But when you're thinking it's the same
thing if you're thinking about your day's
work and whatever your eyes shift and
then you aren't looking through the site.
Right. And you, yeah. You
Miss. Yeah. Yeah. The, the,
all of the things when you're,
when you're shooting a bow,
it's um,
it really is like a form of meditation
and a lot of ways where like for people
that are listening to this,
if you have no desire ever to hunt,
you might be a vegetarian and no desire
to eat meat. Just try archery for fun.
You know, it is, is a really fun,
rewarding discipline
because it does something,
it's like a form of meditation when you
were locked onto that site or locked
onto that, um, target rather,
and everything has to be perfectly aligned
and then you release that Arrow and
then it's sores and sunk right
into the bowls. Like, oh,
it's the most rewarding feelings. It's
weird as Boga. Yeah. Like, uh, yeah,
you gotta, you gotta be focused
and it's practice and it's a cool,
it's a cool sport. I think there's
something in our DNA with archery too.
I really think there's something,
because for thousands of years that
was the best weapon that people had for
hunting.
And I think those people
survived and they survived
by hunting with a bow. Yeah.
So I think every human being that's alive
has in the echo of that DNA in their
system,
the echo of the memories of the people
that survived by airwing a deer and then
the whole family got to eat,
you know? Whereas if you didn't,
you didn't fucking eat. I
mean, and when they were,
when bows were the only
things that you had,
the feeling that they must have had when
they were trying to survive thousands
of years before anybody even bothered
writing things down and they release that
Arrow in,
it's right into the heart of an animal
and you knew where you were eating,
now you're probably fucking starving
when you shot it. You know? I mean,
I think that's in our system.
I think even if you don't want to hunt
and you have no desire to kill an animal
there, it's, it's way better
than shooting. Like if
you shoot a three pointer,
I mean it's Kinda cool, but it's nothing
like an Arrow going into a target.
It's accentuated like
multi times multifold for,
for whatever reason,
when I first started shooting a bow,
I was just a kid and I didn't
know anybody that had bows,
but I'd watch this guys and he was buyer
in Ferguson and his whole thing was
just be the Arrow, instinctive
shooting. It was just a long though.
And what I mean there,
it was the best.
It was the only advice that I had
to shoot a bow with be the air.
What's that mean?
Cause a child be the air.
But I would go out in the backyard
and he was a trick shooter.
He'd throw ring up and shoot through
the ring and she'd like aspirin off his
wife's head. I don't know,
not off her head but like,
like throw up aspirin and at
me often it's aspirin. Yeah.
He would actually shouldn't asprin
in the year with an error. Yeah.
I think the guy has to be one
of the best shots in the world.
Wow.
And it was a with a recurve or a longbow.
Wow. But his, his,
his philosophy is just be the
era. Just shoot how, how it feels.
Don't kind of make sense.
If you get to a certain point,
I guess probably a tennis player must
get to that point to where you have the
same racket for so long and you know the
weight of a ball and you know, you just,
you kind of know where the ball's gone
because you hit it so many times if just
you've done that motion so many times
that like if you watch like Roger Federer
or some of the great tennis players,
they must have like a feel
for where that ball's going.
That's that far surpasses what a guy like
me would never plays tennis could ever
be able to understand.
Yeah.
Because I think there's a certain point
where your brain doesn't work fast
enough for the situation.
So that's where our instincts kick in.
Whenever we get to a situation
that our brain can't compute,
you can't compute the speed that that
aspirin is going in the air and the speed
of your Arrow and the pull of your boat.
You just have to feel what's right.
Yeah. That data has to already
be inside you. Right. Well,
that's the thing about
instinctive shooting with a
bow that doesn't have a site
like a long bar recurve. They just kind
of know where the arrows gone. They don't,
they're not range finding these I that
that's gotta be weird cause you've got to
use the same weight arrows
over and over and over again.
And if you really using traditional
equipment, you're using wooden arrows.
So if you're using consistent,
very inconsistent, you know,
and they could vary by several
grams each arrow and that,
that's a big difference in how far it's
going to fly, how it's going to fly.
Can't really reuse the arrows two
months or the, the blades get dull,
the feathers get fucked up. Yeah. It's um,
you seen that guy on youtube that does
all that crazy archery trick shot stuff
and he carries the, the uh, arrows in
his fingers. No, he never seen him.
The dude can shoot like three times
in the air before it hits the ground.
Like he'll jump off something
and go, hey, can shoot. Like he,
he holds the arrows in his fingers and
some people tried to do this credit him,
I've watched the discrediting him
and I think they're fucking bitter.
I think they're jealous. Good. What
he's doing is fucking amazing. I mean,
w w unless he's using
CGI and faking all of it,
what he's doing is amazing and I think
these bitter bitches need to just get
their own attention some other way.
But they're there.
What he's done is he's found a way to
mimic what he believes is the ancient way
of holding arrows.
He believes they held them
in their fingers and then
they would just be able to
reload like really quickly. They
develop like very good finger dexterity,
whereas we always think of it as like a
quiver and your reach back pulling out
of the quiver. And he's like,
that takes too much time.
And he thinks that this is the guy like
check this shit out. Like, watch this.
Like, watch how he's
holding it. Like that is a,
that's one where he's just
got it. Oh, he's throwing a
fucking, uh, a tab of a beer
and hitting it.
But he's, he does a lot
of jumping. First of all,
this guy looks like he's
never even heard a pussy.
That was his favorite clip. He's like, I
shot the head off a plastic barrier. Yeah.
Well he's um, he, he throws his bow in the
air and you could do it really quickly.
These are not as impressive as the ones
where you holds multiple arrows in his
hands. But it is pretty cool.
Pretty cool. He can do it.
He can do it in the right
hand or the left hand. Um, but
it was broken in the right hand
and the left hand like this is,
you can't disprove this. I mean, this
is, this guy is actually a very ag, oh,
here's one where he's got multiple arrows.
He's got two arrows in his hand.
Wash this one too. Oh God. Oh,
that's a different one. That
was one. He sliced a, uh,
an arrow in half of the knife.
I think it grabs the Arrow and
shoots it before he hits the ground.
Don't try this at home. He's catching
owls. Oh, he's got a weak ass bow.
Child's Beau.
He does.
He does all this crazy
trick shots and see there,
there you see him holding multiple
arrows in between his fingers.
His name is Lars something other. It's
pretty accurate too. It looks like.
Yeah, very accurate. See, look at
that. See how he's holding them.
He's having drinks with people
and shooting them in the face.
He's imagining himself in the old west.
See this is,
this is their arrows and a quiver and
now look, he holds them in his hand,
but now this is his style
and the draw hand. See,
see how they used to do that.
Like these are some ancient hieroglyphs.
They showed some ancient photos.
They showed them holding the
arrows in their hands as they shot.
And so he's trying to recapture
this old way of doing archery.
That's cool. Yeah. Archery's
fascinating man. It's uh,
it's just a fascinating thing that someone
figured out a long time ago that you
could attach a string to a stick
and if you pull that stick back,
it's got energy that goes, throws it,
wants it to go back the way it came.
And if you put another stick on
that string, he can kill some shit.
Yeah,
that's it.
It's been around for a long
time and it's effective still.
Yeah. Well guys like Cam Haynes, he
uh, you know, he only hunts with,
with a bow and he's like a rifle on.
He's just not fun. Like I don't enjoy it.
He was like, I have to get the,
I, I've, I can be really far away.
Barely see the thing, lay
it on a rock, look to scope,
squeeze the trigger in the animal's
dead. He's like, it's just the,
the amount of thrill and the amount of
skill involved is just so much less that
for him it's just,
it's not worth doing.
Yeah. I enjoy bow hunting a lot and I also
enjoy rifle hunting though. I'd still,
I kind of didn't rifle
hunt for a long time.
And then once I started filming
my own hunts, I was like, hm.
I might just pick up this rifle and make
it. And it's just as hard as, I mean,
it depends where you're hunting too.
Cause when I go on a rifle hunting,
a lot of times I'm going into a
place that is so hard to hunt.
Even sometimes just getting
there is a challenge.
And then finding one animal is a challenge
and then getting to where you could
shoot that animal and they're
taking it with a rifle.
And I've been on a lot of bow hunts there,
a thousand times easier than many
of the rifle hands I've done.
So there's kind of a,
a thought where a lot of times
I'll go on a hunt and take a rifle.
Not because it makes
it easier or it might,
it wouldn't be impossible with
a bow, but it's, it's just,
it's so challenging in the first place
that the challenge is there. Well,
you're doing it in a completely different
way than anybody else because as you
said, you're, you're filming.
Yeah. I mean there's,
there's other hunts where I've
gone on and I haven't, you know,
or I might not be filming,
but you go into an area with such a low
densities that you might have to walk a
hundred miles before you
even see an animal. Well,
that was one of the episodes you
did recently was a deer hunt. Yeah.
You went on purpose to low density
area. Yeah. Just because I,
I was thinking no one else is going here,
so that's why you weren't just cause
you knew you were going to be alone and
it's going to be hard. And I thought, no,
I'll just stick it out
and see what happens.
There's one episode of Rinella show
where he went elk hunting and everywhere
they looked,
there was hunters.
There's was like orange vests coming
up this hill going down that hill,
going towards these elk and
like, wow, that's a, that's
a drag for two reasons. One,
because it's kind of like,
it becomes a competitive race to try
to get to the elk first. But also too,
you don't know these guys. You don't
know what, what they're doing. They know.
You don't know like how, how squeezy
they are, how trigger happy they are.
You know, like some guy
got shot this year, uh,
elk hunting with a bow in the leg or
some guy who was stuck in for an elk.
That's bad. That's terrible. If
you mistake someone with a bow.
Yeah.
Like what the fuck man,
that guys is shooting at every
there that that's not normal.
No, no. But with a rifle it would be like,
a lot of weird shit can happen with
people shooting shot. They shouldn't make,
they don't know what's behind the
animal. They didn't, you know,
they just take a chance to
take a flyer and you know,
it's just when you have to take into
account other people's ideas of safety and
you have to take that into consideration.
It kind of ruins the whole idea of honey.
Yeah.
I like hunting animals that are
acting as animals and not as animals.
They're acting as hunted animals.
I guess because it was too different.
It's a little more predictable
in one sense, but you're,
you're in a natural environment
hunting an animal as the animal exists.
And that to me is what it's all about.
I like to be out there a lot of times by
myself and not see another person. Yeah.
There's,
there is a big difference between the
way animals act when they're not hunted
around people. And, uh, like
I was in boulder and uh,
my wife and I were visiting this house,
visiting these people and uh,
we went into the backyard and this
fucking giant mule deer in velvet is just
walking straight towards us,
just straight towards us. And,
and my wife's like, do you want, would
you want to shoot that deer? I like,
I could never shoot that
deer. It's just dog, a pet.
That thing's coming right towards us.
Like it wasn't even a little,
a little nervous. It was just
walking like this did it, but up.
But looking at us right in the eye,
a big ass 10 pointer.
I got big old mule deer too. He didn't, he
was like, he's been in his town forever.
This is my town. Bitch. People
aren't predators to him at all.
It's actually probably a food source. She
sees people when they throw apples out,
probably. Yeah. We, uh, at
one point in time we pulled
over the side of the road. Um,
my girls had never seen it.
They've seen deers in our yard before,
but they never seen like a big buck to
standing on the side of the road. And, uh,
we pulled over to the side of the road
and we got out of the car and I said,
well, I just want you to stay
close to them because I don't,
he'll do anything but just in case we'll
stay on this side of the road and he'll
be on the other side.
We're just separated by the road.
And he's just looking at us and just goes
back to just looking at us and they're
like, that's so cool. And he was like,
what the fuck? They bolted and he's like,
I don't know what that noise is.
It sounds like a war cry.
Let me get out of here as a five year
old. What's it kill me? But it's just,
it's so strange when you see them when
they're around people because they become
like squirrels, you know, they
just, they just sort of hang out.
Yeah. Yeah. They, I dunno. For me,
part of hunting is just being in
that place that's remote and wild and
adventurous and a way to get away and
either by yourself and be in nature and
so, I mean obviously there's places
that you hunt that are closer,
but also I think my thing is just kind
of going to places that aren't private
ranches that aren't just real wild places
and going in there and working hard
and trying to hunt animals
that may not have seen people.
Yeah. When you see something hasn't seen
a person or when there's just no people
around. There's this weird
moment when you, when you,
when you lock eyes on them and you're
seeing them and you don't have to exist.
You, you, you, you mean? Yeah.
They would be doing exactly that same
thing whether or not you were ever born
and you enter into their world
and it's this, it's a very weird,
I want to say like a transcendent
experience because you're in the wild,
you're in the real wild and you get
the sense of that, that these animals,
they live there and they
lived there looking out for
wolves or bears or whatever
the fuck they're, they're worried about.
It's not people they're worried about.
Yeah.
I think it's cool too because you see,
you see a different landscape
than everybody else sees
because like when you're
hunting,
you're never on a trail.
You're going cross country through places
that someone else would never have a
reason to be there,
you know?
So those have been a lot of places that
I've been in, sat down and thought,
I wonder if anybody else has ever
even been right here. I mean,
maybe they've been in this area, but
have, has anyone ever been right here?
And why would they be here if
they weren't hunting? But I was,
I was actually thinking
about this the other day.
I was in a spot when time I
backpacked in just had camping out.
Extremely remote place to start off.
Hiked in along ways? No, he was right.
It was that thought like there's probably
nobody has been here and I set up camp
for the night and I had a bag of
potato chips and I'm like, okay,
we need these chips, open up the
chips and it's starting to get dark.
He to chip and I dropped one on the
ground and I'm setting up my tent and
amounts runs out and grabs the
potato chip and starts eating it.
How does that mouse know
that it can eat potato chips?
That has perplexed me till this day.
Like is that mouse born knowing
that it can eat peanut oil,
fried potato chips? That's a
really good question. I I it it,
it's beyond like I can't figure that out.
I would think that would be a risk for
them. I would think so too. Or how,
why would it even think that that was
food? Because I was eating, it was like,
this isn't like in in the middle of
nowhere and eating a bag of potato chips
going here. These are some
energy. This isn't bad,
but it's not natural looking food.
It doesn't taste natural.
It probably doesn't smell
like anything. Woods. No,
and I'm thinking this mouse has
definitely never had human contact.
Like if you're in a town or something and
I would just, yeah, Paige and z thing.
They know it's food.
They've seen other animals eat that food.
How did this mouse know that it can eat,
eat potato chips?
That's a very good question.
I would like to talk to a mouse x,
but I want to do something.
I mean they do enough studies on them.
I'm sure there's one out there. Yeah.
I wonder if the, maybe it's a salt.
Maybe they could smell the
salt. I Dunno. You know,
cause I know animals gravitate
towards those salt blocks.
Those don't make any sense. Yeah. They
leave leave down for deer. They need to,
maybe that's what it is. Maybe you just
recognizes the fact that salts on it.
They could probably smell the salt.
That's what I was thinking.
Cause I did recently for
a new apex episode, um,
a foraging thing, just going
out and finding foods, uh,
much like a bare wood, but I,
I'm trying to think as a human,
do we really have that innate ability
to distinguish poisonous plants from non
poisonous plants? Not really. Not really,
but I don't know. Is it something,
maybe it's passed down or if you
were just left on an island alone,
would you figure out what you could eat?
Boy,
you'd have to be fucking real careful
with things like mushrooms. Yeah.
So that was one of the cool things that
I learned is there's actually way more
poisonous plants then there are
poisonous mushrooms. Really? Yeah.
Well there's a lot more plants I guess.
But I mean for the amount of
edible plants that there are,
there's a lot more
plants that are inedible.
So the percentage of plants being
poisonous is higher than the percentage of
mushrooms being poisonous.
This was coming from a guy who's like
a mushroom expert and that's what his
pitch was. He was like a pro mushroom.
Yeah. I think he's real premise,
much like forward. Yeah.
But uh, yeah, there was,
there's actually a lot there. I think
there's a lot of mushrooms that yeah.
Will kill you dead.
And then there's some that will make
you sick and then there's some that are
just, you can't really eat. And
then there's some you can't eat.
There's a few though that are pretty
common. That'll kill you dead. Yeah.
That's very disconcerting.
It is.
But I think there's a lot of plants that
will kill you. Dead to a lot of berries.
Oh yeah. I'm sure. Yeah. Yeah. I don't
know shit about plants that you can eat.
If I was left alone in the woods
and I had to figure out what to eat,
I'd be fucked.
There's a lot of basics.
You learn like 10 basics that are kind
of everywhere. Like what are the basics?
You've got like cat tails and dandy line,
like just common plants
that are [inaudible] things.
My grandmother used to make
salad chicken. You, um, violets,
violets, like the rose, like a flower
rather. Yeah. You can eat those plants,
everything.
Um,
you probably wouldn't do it,
one of those flowers on it so
you can identify it easily. Oh,
you want to do a lot as flowers on
it? Um, unless you know what though,
there's a lot of lookalikes plantation,
which is just kind of like a roadside.
I mean, he's all over
the place. It's not like,
not like playing tanes but it's a plant.
It's called plantation,
but it's not like a banana,
right? Correct. Yeah. Yeah.
I watched that survivor man show Les
Stroud and he would go and he's a real
expert in what you can and can't eat.
And shockingly,
how little you could find
shocking. Yeah, that's,
that's kind of the thing
that struck me is as a human,
like a bear when they were plants,
they die off in the winter.
So then what do you eat? Like I
think a lot of people, I, I've,
I've heard people say like, oh, humans,
our digestive system is more plant based,
which we were opportunistic omnivores
as well as predatory omnivores.
But once that plant base runs out,
we can't digest the same things dear Ken.
So what are we left too?
We have to hunt essentially.
Well,
when people say that that we primarily
exist on plant based diets or that we
can,
or should they,
they don't take into account things like
Inuits who don't have any cancer at all.
They don't eat any vegetables, no
fruits, nothing. So lots of seal.
Yeah.
Fats.
They eat fats and fishes and
wail and anything they can kill.
I mean that's a, that throws a big monkey
wrench into that whole theory. I don't,
I don't buy that because I think too much
of that. When people say those things,
it's ideologically based.
Whether people say, you know,
you should own like people that are like,
I don't need vegetables. I eat all meat.
I think that's ridiculous when people
say that because I think vegetables
without a doubt,
a really good for you.
I feel better when I eat a
lot of vegetables. I think
it's really good for you,
but when people say that you
should only eat vegetables, I go,
but that doesn't make any sense
either because that's not,
that's not evidence based.
That's ideologically based.
It's like there's a good balance.
Yeah. But people that say that,
they're almost always
like animal rights people.
They're almost always vegan
and they're almost always,
you're like really into animals and
the idea that we don't have to consume
animals, which I kind of see what
you're, I see what you're saying.
I don't agree with it,
but I see what you're saying.
But when you say that it's healthier,
it's better for people or
it's an ideological, you know,
it doesn't, that doesn't make sense.
Like logically know on either side.
I mean, we can't just
eat, well we can, but can.
Eating only meat and eating like
omnivores, we should eat both.
But I mean, my personal belief is that
we should hunt for the meat that we eat.
And not everyone can do that, but it's
just, for me, it's a more natural system.
It makes more sense to me. That
is the real problem, right?
Because not everyone can do it.
The real problem is we've fucked
ourselves in this position,
literally fucked ourselves into this
position where we have 20 million people
jammed into a city. Right? I mean,
that's what we did and we fucked
until we ran out of space.
And now we have all these people piled
up and we have to keep trucking food into
this fuck festival that we call cities.
And no one's growing anything. I mean,
we have these goddamned giant chunks
of property that people are, you know,
packed into an apartment,
buildings and houses and fucking roads
and no one's growing a goddamn thing.
And there, there's so many ornamental
plants that have no utility.
What did we just replaced? Every plant
you couldn't eat with a plant. You could,
yeah, palm trees. Fucking palm
tree has those, those do fruit.
But we, they cut them off.
We don't want anybody dying.
Do you know 150 people die every year
because coconuts fall on their head.
That's, that's a bad day.
All across the world.
150 people worldwide a
year from coconuts bonk.
Larry would be with us today.
Horrible coconut accident.
Well, you gotta think man,
a full coconut. Like I bought one
the other day from supermarket.
And when you got, when you, for people
who've never seen a coconut in the wild,
when you're buying them
from a supermarket, they've
already been husked. Yeah,
like so a you're getting
the inside the outside is,
is hard sort of a husk that makes it
quite a bit heavier and you got to chop
through all that to get to the round
brown piece and you chop through that and
that's how you get the milk and the
fruit, the coconut, a white stuff itself.
But with one of those falls from,
you know,
80 90 feet up and hits you in
the head, you fucking gone, dude.
That's a rat. It's a lot of
weight coming down real fast.
I had a buddy used to live in Hawaii
and they used to pick fresh mangoes.
They'd go pick wild mangoes,
just walked down this road and they
would find with mangoes and grab him and
take like a basket full of mangoes home.
So like, wow. Like if you live in Hawaii,
you kind of can forage for
fresh fruit for to live.
Yeah. I recently found,
I recently heard this,
and maybe it's incorrect,
but I'm pretty sure it's true that main
NGOs are somewhat related to poison ivy.
So if you're highly allergic to
poison ivy or poison oak or Sumac,
then mangoes you would probably be
allergic to as well. Really? Yeah.
Wow. Find that out Jamie. I that that
should be, yeah, that should be looked at.
I should be,
but I do because I recently got poison
oak or poison ivy and so I was just
looking it up. Is that the only time
you've ever had it? Yeah. Really? Yeah.
That's crazy. And it wasn't, it wasn't
that bad, but it was days later,
so it must have uh huh on your toes.
Maybe when I washed everything together,
like through the rain
gear and when we were, um,
we were hunting turkeys in Napa for
a mediator and there was poison oak
everywhere and everyone was terrified
of it. All. A bunch of guys on the crew.
Got It. Yeah. But I fucking
went way out of the way to not get an
it took my clothes off outside the car,
put them. I was like in my
underwear outside. I don't
give a fuck. Come look. Yeah.
I'm throwing my shit in a bag in the back,
not touching it with my hands,
taking it out from there.
When I got home,
I made sure that anything that might
have come in contact with that stuff
because Rinella was saying he got
it on his dick. That's a bad day.
A lot of bad days. Shit
cooking. It's fun on your head.
No worst place, I would think.
Yeah, that's the worst place.
But you think about it,
if you're touching the trees and then
you have to go to take a leak and you get
it on your deck. Is it true?
Oh, it's true. It's true.
Dodged the bullet on that one. You're
like, wow, this is what a weird word.
U. R. U. S. H. I. O.
L. How do you say that?
Ooh,
she all Rochelle.
Is it chemical found in the oil
of the mango, SAP or Schwab?
It was also found a poison
ivy and poison oak. Therefore,
people who have a history or reactions
to poison ivy and poison oak should be
cautious when handling mangoes.
Wow, that's interesting.
Very interesting. Uh,
when I did fear factor,
we found out that if you are allergic to
shellfish are also allergic to roaches,
same,
same exact enzyme and a roaches.
And so people that we had on the show,
well I should say person, one dude,
he ate a bunch of roaches and he
had shellfish allergy and it just,
his throat closed up to the side of like
a, like a soda pop Straw. And they look,
they probably didn't test for
that, you know, will they panicked?
They had to take this guy to the hospital,
they'd give him a shot.
I think we had an EMT standing by always.
Um,
so I think gave him a shot of adrenaline,
adrenaline or something like that.
Epinephrine, you think? What do
you, is that what they give him?
And then they send him to the hospital
and they kicked him off the show.
Get out of here, kid. You loose, keep
your mouth shut. It's never happened.
And we dodged so many
bullets on that show.
There's that show man. I mean, they did
a great job with, don't get me wrong,
did a great job with stunts.
They plan things out well in advance and
they got approval from the network for
every step of the way,
but they dodged a lot of bullets.
Was there anything on there
that you thought to yourself?
I kind of want to try that. Oh
yeah, yeah. A bunch of them.
Like especially the car stunts,
like flipping cars off the
top of a building because uh,
they would flip them into these
gigantic stacks of cardboard boxes.
That's how they would,
um, do the Karstens.
So they would have these folded up
cardboard boxes and they would stack them
like the size of a building,
like w two stories up.
And they had a crew of guys that would
go in there and stack these boxes so that
they had boxes like that have a cardboard
box. It was like in the inside of,
it was like an ex and they would close
the box and then put another one on top
of it.
And close that backs up,
put another one on top of it and they
would have like stacked up 50 boxes high
and then they would flip these cars
through the air off the top of
like a 10 story building and boom,
we just landed on this giant building of
boxes of cardboard boxes and then sink
to the bottom. But it was totally safe
that way and it was so cool. Huh? That's,
that's what I wanted to try.
What I've always wondered this because
I remember watching an episode of fear
factor. What? What's the deal with those
hundred year old eggs? It wasn't that,
it's not really a hundred
year old. What's, yeah, what's
the, it's an expression.
It's the Chinese call it
a hundred year old eggs.
And what it means is it's
a style of fermenting where
they would take an egg and
they would bury it in the ground.
And I don't remember the whole process,
but it's only really like a few months
old. Okay. But they become black.
Yeah.
The white becomes but nasty to us.
But to Chinese people it's a
delicacy. Oh, okay. So it's,
it is something that people,
well that was one of the things
that we had to do early on.
We could only serve people something that
someone somewhere eight in the world.
Gotcha. So like if we, we serve
people eyeballs like sheeps, eyeballs.
That's a pretty common
thing that people eat.
Especially in places where they
don't have much money. It's,
there's protein in that.
Don't throw it away, eat it.
So there's a history of
people eat cheap side balls.
We could serve cheap side
eyeballs, bugs, placenta,
placenta, the, believe it or not.
Right. That's a weird one. People Cook
it. That's disgusting. That's in Christ.
I've eaten a lot of strange things,
but the most recently string,
I tried to eat a live slug that,
oh, don't do that. No. Why did you,
my fucking chickens don't
even like those things.
It immediately builds up this amazing
amount of like film in your mouth makes
everything. It was the, you almost have,
I guess you can get some kind of
brain worm from it as well. The,
at first I kind of bit it in half
to kind of get it and I was like,
and then immediately I regretted.
It was instantaneous,
but it took a few seconds. It was, it
was all the same. It was like one bite,
two bites, and I was
like, what's happening?
This is not good. And at
that moment I realized, no,
humans have no clue what you can eat and
go like, why did you have to eat it raw?
I did well for the show, obviously
I didn't have to, I just found it.
I was thinking, well, I've
never eaten a raw slug.
And I was thinking about it and
I was in my mind, I was like,
I know there's something strange
about him. I know won't kill you.
And I was like, Yep, this
is why people don't do it.
Well you and Rinella eight a
coyote on that Mexico. So that was,
that was hard to watch. It wasn't that,
it wasn't that bad. It wasn't good.
It wasn't bad. But when you burn the
hair off of it, that's what I was like,
oh Jesus Christ to dipping,
dipping in that pond water.
Cause like it was a stagnant
pool in northern Mexico.
You just ask you
how the new aids he just
asking to create it. Oh God.
So we got coyote aids
from singed coyote over.
Now let's got everything. He,
he's, I, he, he's got it all man.
He's had everything.
He had Giardia and Lyme
disease at the same time.
That's the worst combination of things
you can have because he got a trick.
GNOSIS too. He got trick analysis
as well. And so now when,
once I found out he got tricked nurses,
I thought if Steve Rinella can get tricky
gnosis anybody can get your notices
because he, him talking about bears
and trick gnosis goes hand in hand.
And when you're cooking
over a fire though,
a lot of this stuff you eat
is undercooked. Yeah. Um,
so I recently went on a bear hunt and
brought a meat thermometer with me and
ate.
I eat some brown bear because I wasn't,
I always hear that Brown bear is inedible.
And I, I'm just one of those people. I,
I'm not going to believe it until I've
tried it because I've heard a lot of
other things don't taste good.
And I have a really good,
I'm defending myself in however, a really
good sense of taste. That's like what?
A slug and my mouth. But, uh, I thought
it was the best bear I've ever eaten.
Really? Yeah. And,
and was it interior was through
coastal and it was eating a seal,
a dead seal carcass. And it was
good, but it was a younger bear.
It wasn't, I mean, for meat, I,
it was better than any black
bear I've ever had. Real.
Yeah. Was it the backstraps?
Yeah, every, all of it. So you
ate everything and was this,
how did you cook it over? Well, we started
over the fire. I've done, it was good.
It was good. She could see, you could
visibly see like parasites, worms,
and some of the areas like around
stomach and eau Claire places.
But that's why I was
meat thermometer time.
But you could visibly see the
parasites. Wow. So I think that,
I think that immediately makes
people think it's going to be bad.
I don't know. I'm
bringing my a bear to, uh,
the bear that I have left to a
sausage guy. Uh, Bakersfield.
It makes good sausage.
Yeah, that's, that's probably the best
way to do it. We don't worry about it.
This guy makes a sausage and he
makes a really good summer sausage.
So if you get the summer sausage,
sorry, already cooked. You know,
just probably a good thing for
something like bare. But there's that,
that one element always
kind of bums me out,
but you always have to worry
about and having a parasite,
that's what I really like about deer or
elk or something like that is that you
don't have to think about
that. You eat it. Pretty rare.
Yeah, it's really good. Yeah. You got,
you almost have to under cook it
because once it, there's no fat in it,
so if you cook it too
much, it's just dry. Not,
I think a lot of people almost don't
like wild meat because they don't prepare
it. Right? Yeah. It gets chewy. It's
real chewy and like, but if done right,
nothing better. Yeah. I was
at, uh, elk camp. These guys are putting
a one steak sauce on elk. I was like,
you guys should all go to jail,
shall be in jail for this. This is,
this should be illegal.
This one guy took all of
his elk and grounded up,
made hamburger out of everything. The
whole elk. All of it. Yeah. I was like,
that seems, I mean, look sick. Yeah. Elk
Burger tastes great. Don't get me wrong,
but why are you doing that?
Like when do you not know how to cook it?
Like that seems crazy.
Yeah. I like, I like cooking it in
large pieces. Almost like a roast. Yeah.
The back strap, big pieces, and then
slicing it after it's cooked that way.
It's always, it's cooked. Right. It's
such a distinct flavor that you were,
you know,
the only way you get it from a store
or is it they get it from New Zealand,
which is really weird. Yeah. And those,
if you get deer like venison,
it doesn't distinguish what it is.
Most of the time it's a red
deer or fallow deer. Oh really?
So if you get venison from the New
Zealand red deer valley and there,
there I,
I call him like a lot raised but grass
fed because the grass grows so easy and
well over there. They know
green. Yeah, there's no,
there's not a lot of supplemental we
winter feeding or anything like that.
So it's grass fed.
Most of the time no pesticides or any
of that kind of stuff would be added.
Just not necessary because the,
the animals there don't have
a lot of the things that we,
I mean they have
tuberculosis but that's a,
they don't have like mad cow
over there or anything like that.
So they don't have to,
they don't have a lot of the bugs that
we have in some places they have ticks
but not everywhere.
So they don't have to do a lot of things.
So it is fairly clean meat or consider it.
Which is weird that we have so
many deer and elk over here.
But yet when you buy meat,
a good percentage of it is
coming from New Zealand.
Yeah. Because it's, well, you
can't sell wild gave me in America.
That's wild because,
and I see the reason for it because
once you put a value on something up,
monetary value, then people
opt to break the law even more.
It's like rhinos and elephants and all.
If there was no value of the horns or the
tusks, no one would care. They wouldn't.
No one would shoot him. Yeah.
Illegally. Yeah. I mean,
rhino tastes good. Corey Knowlton said
that it was one of the best meats.
He's every, when he shot that ball,
expensive steak. I would say that too.
Like when I spend $30
on a steak that's gone.
That was the best steak I ever had.
When you spend $350,000 to shoot it and
endangered rhino and then eat it and
then get death threats for the
next six months. Yeah, pretty much.
Every day you're like, that's,
you're eating a steak on the house.
It's so worth it. Or He's
too, it was really good. He
said, be gentlemanly. Good.
I've heard hippos really good as well.
It's a big, it's a cousin of a pig, right,
isn't it? I'm not sure about that.
I think hippos related to a pig.
I think it's like the cousin of a pig.
Something along those lines.
Just a giant nasty pig. You said you've
seen that video where the pig is a,
or the hippo rather is chasing
the people on a speedboat. Nope.
That's such a crazy video. See if
you can find that video, Jamie,
because these guys are in a boat and
they're trying to get away in this hippo
swimming after him,
like just charging in the water after
him and like his right on their ass and
it's as big as the boat. It's
fucking enormous. They move fast.
Got Fast.
I was in Africa and a friend of mine,
um,
there's a Ph there and I was helping out.
He h means
professional hunter. Yeah.
That's like a guide in America.
They call them professional hunters
and Africa for folks listening.
And so there was a problem.
Hippo is
one that was a danger and could kill
people. So we went in there to go find it.
Um,
and the speed that they move was insane.
I've never seen anything
Matt size move that fast.
It kind of freaks you out because you're
in real tight quarters and it's in the
water and you see these bubbles just
coming. It's like guarantee towards you.
Yeah.
To get you. Oh, here it is. Watch this.
Check this out.
Hello.
He takes off.
But then he says the hippo just explode
or huge coming within just a few feet of
the back of the boat.
The driver gunned the engine getting
away in just the nick of time,
I looked this up,
the size of that thing.
You know that hippos are highly
aggressive and unpredictable and the most
dangerous mammal in Africa.
I would never have known that.
Thank goodness he gunned it.
Well, the size of that fucking thing.
Yeah. People don't know because a hungry,
hungry hippo. Yeah, I have. I play that
with my five year old the other day.
See it's cause Disneyland stop that
ride where they shoot at the hip us.
They had a ride where you shooting?
It wasn't the,
I think it was some kind
of jungle boat thing.
I remember that as a kid in the guide
would like pretend like you're shooting at
the hippos. Oh really? They stopped it.
I think we'll call you a monster now.
You Monster Hippos shot the whole movie.
They probably stopped that 20 years ago.
I do.
Well,
there's so many weird things that
we've turned cute like polar bears,
polar bears.
You saw Klondike bars and Coca Cola,
you know hippos.
They're like,
they're sweet and they dance around their
bows in their hair to tears. I mean,
we've done some weird things
to animals. I mean, Yogi Bear,
Yogi bears a fucking grizzly man.
You'll get bear lives in Yellowstone park,
right? Yeah. That's where he's supposed to
live. Or He's supposed to live in jelly,
jelly stone. But it's basically
the same thing. Yeah, he's big.
He's way too big to be a black
bear. Right? He's fucking giant.
Joe Yogi shoot wears a hat. You
know, it was Harry boom, boom.
Just trying to get a little picnic basket.
You know what I mean? What did we do?
We, we confuse the shit out a
little kids. And then Bambi, Bambi.
Bambi was the one that
ruined hunting for everybody.
And it also, Bambi is uh,
a buck. It's man's name.
Apparently. Bam. He's a
man's. Think about it.
Bambi was a buck.
So we associate Bambi with female
Bambi was a female. No, it's a,
well the bucks were never
taken care of the offspring.
That's why that movie stupid
bammies a boy named sue really?
Cause like his dad knew he wouldn't be
around. So I'm going to name you Bambi.
You're going to grow up to be tough. So
everybody missed the point of that movie.
That's really what it was about.
A lot of hunters,
we'll talk about that
movie like it's like,
like it was the end of good days.
I feel like it changed the way America
received hunting because all of a sudden
you get this adorable Bambi is adorable,
sweet deer and it was right around
the same time or Rudolph the red nose
reindeer came out. But there's,
there's no cows. No across that way.
Cows are fucked
dumping.
There's no happy cows in California.
There's happy cows. But are there,
I was driving to La today
and saw so many happy cows.
I think you're talking about people.
It's Deborah.
I passed no less than 12
McDonald's on the way. So gross.
Such a culture shock for me because I
literally spend most of my life around
very few people.
And even yesterday I was just out in
the mountains of Montana guiding hunters
and then I come here and look around
and you just feel like, holy smokes,
this is reality here. Whole well this
is this reality, this reality. Yeah.
It's completely different
than what I'm used to.
And I think a lot of people don't realize
that there are people live completely
different than them. People in Montana.
I have no clue what this world isn't.
The people here have no clue what that
world is. I Love Montana, I love it.
I was just in Bozeman last week.
Yeah,
we're pheasant hunting for a board
Danes TV show and we're wandering around
Bozeman. It's like, what a great place.
Isn't Bozeman? Awesome. So amazing. Yeah.
So Zpz you know the Steve
Show and they do 0.0 0.0 they,
they've just opened like an office
in Bozeman, so I get to go there
and loved that dude. Man. Bozeman
is a cool town. Fast is Scott.
It's just got a cool
vibe and even like that,
well I guess the town is essentially 47
bars down main street interspersed with
sandwich and steak shops.
So I guess really there's
nothing not to like about it.
Yeah, it's pretty much perfect. Yeah.
Not that many people city over the whole
state has like a million people, right?
Yeah, I think the whole state. Yeah. Yeah.
And there's the largest state
or it's, yeah, it's by volume.
It's the third largest state
and it has like what you said,
like less than a million people and
no traffic, just that doesn't exist.
There's no traffic jams. Five o'clock.
What happens? Nothing. He'd just drive.
It's like normal and I mean all around it.
There's just,
you can be in the mountains,
you can get away from toddlers,
big wilderness and Oh, it's beautiful. We
saw a lot of antelope, lot of pronghorn.
We saw, um, lot. We saw quite
a bit. Pheasants. I didn't
get one, but uh, wow. Shit.
I'm supposed to probably not supposed
to say what happened on the show.
It's a mystery, but somebody did. He's
taller than me. He's got great hair. Uh,
we saw mule deer were out
there. It's just, it's
beautiful. It's fucking amazing.
Such a great state.
It's, it's wild. I mean,
it is as close to wild and real
wilderness as you can get in America.
And Alaska is another notch above that.
I go the Alaska, Alaska is like, oh yeah,
check this out, bitch. Yeah,
we got, we got even bigger.
That's probably the biggest state.
Alaska, yeah. Yeah. The biggest date.
At least amount of people. It's probably
got the least amount of people. Right,
and that makes sense. Yes. It technically
Montana's not the third largest state.
I guess it'd be, I think it's the
third California, right? I don't know.
I'd heard it was the third. They kept
saying it was the third. Maybe it is.
Whatever it is. It's
giant. I forgot where Miss,
I'm not smarter than a fifth
grader. Well, it's not smart.
It's information that's absorbed.
If you're really smart,
you would have actually gone out there
and measured it, right? But the, uh,
the mountains out there,
there's something amazing about them.
There's something amazing about like that
kind of solitude when you're in those
areas where you, you sit down,
you could sit down on the ridge,
like if you're glassing or stuff
like that and you just hear nothing.
You see your when
and you look out and you realize this
mountain doesn't give a fuck if you exist.
It doesn't, it doesn't care if
you're here. If you're gone,
if you fall off this cliff and smash
your head on the rocks still there.
Okay.
Same. Exactly the same. You know, some
animals will find you, they'll eat you.
And that's a wrap, you know? And
then everything keeps moving,
keeps moving the same direction. It always
has thousands and thousands of years.
And then we think that the mountains
themselves came about through seismic
activity that forced the crust of the
earth to shift and move upwards and to
thousands and thousands
of feet above sea level,
like fucking crazy place. It
is me. While you were in la,
chicken out McDonald's, we're happy
camps when you're doing this show.
And we briefly touched on it before.
It's called Apex Predator and it's on
the uh, outdoors network outdoorsman,
outdoor channel, outdoor
channel, sportsmen's network,
sportsmans channel and the outdoor
channel. And the outdoor channel, um, has,
uh, your show, you're,
you're trying to imitate the
methods that various animals use in,
in trying to survive and
in hunt prey. And, uh,
I got curious about a couple of these
that I haven't seen yet. First of all,
the mountain line one, what did you do
for the mountain? Mine warm. So yeah,
so the show is kind of a,
I see it as almost a natural history
lesson where we're looking at humans are,
in my opinion,
undoubtably the species on the planet
because we can adapt so many things
that other animals do so well.
But the other thing that we're looking
at is how did humans become these top
hunters? It's called Apex Predator.
Not that I'm the Apex Predator,
they were studying apex predators,
but humans as a whole are pretty
much at the top of the food chain.
And we can look at everything a certain
animal does or something in nature
that's specialized and possibly
try to mimic it in a way.
And so with the mountain lion episode,
what we did is the mountain
lion is a very silent predator.
They're quiet. And that's one of
the reasons they're so effective.
And so my thought was,
well,
can humans be as quiet as a mountain lion?
How do we do this?
So I looked at a mountain lion and met
with the mountain line expert and then we
actually did some experiments
on the mountain lion as
far as measuring its force.
It exerts on the ground and
how essentially how loud
it isn't when it walks in
the way it walks and s with slow
motion cameras and everything.
And then I tried to mimic that in a
certain way by using moccasins or,
or even bare feet.
And w what would I found out
while doing this is pretty cool.
I don't want to give it all away, but
humans really like the way we walk now.
We heel strike and it's a forceful impact
and without forceful impact does is it
puts, because we're by
Peter, we put, you know,
all of our weight on one foot at a time
pretty much as we're moving our feet and
that's allowed and especially
the way we do it. But as humans,
modern footwear has dictated the way
we now walk with our heel strike.
We used to walk almost identical
to the mountain line with our,
with our PTOs first slowly rolling
our planet and being quiet.
So we've kind of evolved into this allowed
bumbling animal when originally we,
we naturally are quiet
like the mountain lion.
I've tried to run that way on your,
on your daughter's hose and
it feels so odd. It does.
It feels like I'm doing it wrong, you
know, cause and uh, the, the, the design,
like what you're saying of footwear
is what is making people run.
He'll first its running shoes,
you know,
I mean obviously we found
out and makes you faster,
but then you have all these injuries.
I think it has to,
I don't know because the way it was
explained to me is yeah, you're,
you're propelling forward off your toes.
So that's giving you more ground
force to push off at a running gait.
Um,
because if you land on your toe,
you have to lean forward more and you
don't have as much ground force exerted
because you're using the inertia of the
heel to roll forward and push forward.
That makes sense. Um,
but I mean it makes us,
I think sort of,
yeah,
it's got to make us faster as is
what it was explained to me. But it,
whereas when you're on your toes,
you absorb more shock.
So I think you have,
I would probably less injury,
well,
when I first started reading
about this and hearing this,
I watched my kids run around
and especially when they're
run around barefoot and
they run PTOs first test first,
it's just that's natural for that natural
way to walk different. Yeah. It's,
and it's hard to,
it's hard to reverse because you're
trained so much to walk like that,
but they're only real way
to do it is just go without,
I used moccasins because there's a lot
of it was you can actually still feel the
ground,
the same as just a piece of leather to
keep the thorns and everything else.
Cause I was going miles a day and your
feet would get tired and sore and you had
to walk on your toes because
otherwise your knees hurt your,
your whole body or you'd have to,
there's no way to do it otherwise.
When you're barefoot, when is that going
to change the way you wear footwear?
When you go hunting? Do you, do you wear
like a thick, heavy mountain boot? Um,
what boot I wear depends on
the terrain and what I'm doing,
but generally if I'm stocking,
you know,
it's something I generally just take
my shoes off. I always have, um,
go in my socks or barefoot or it's
just to be quiet. Yeah. Because that,
uh, you know, the stiff sole of a boot,
you can't feel the ground as a hunter.
You really need to be able to feel the
ground snapping twigs and things along
those lines. Yeah. I think there's,
there's a lot of things that hunters do
that I think a lot of people may not do.
And I notice it when I guide people or
whatever. Even guys that hunt a lot,
but maybe not the type of hunting
that I do, even the way we walk,
a lot of people walk in, they look
down at the ground. I don't get that.
They don't want to step on anything.
Yeah. But yet it's because we don't,
we've, same thing, we've, we no
longer need to feel the ground,
but it should be walking with
our heads up, looking around.
We know how to walk and
know what's in front of us.
That's when the poisonous seed, right. I
think that's what people worry about. No,
that's the bear that gets you while
you're sleeping so you shouldn't sleep.
That's right. You should look around
and walk. She asleep during the day,
clean bear's asleep.
And that's the move that is
the move or sleeping I no Trey,
but if you fall, uh, yeah, the move is a,
there is no move like you have to the
movies your truck. That's right. Yeah.
I sleep in the fucking truck. I've always
thought that that's gotta be the mood.
Like sleep, sleep in some sort
of a camper type situation.
Those ones that I saw
that have, uh, it was, uh,
they had it on a Land Cruiser where the,
uh,
it was like a shelf that folds over and
then a ladder comes down the ladder acts
as sort of a prop.
And then from there they,
they pop this tent up and
then just sleeping on the
roof of the truck. I'm like,
that's perfect. Yes. I saw him
once at a trail head and thought,
well that's pretty neat. Also kind of
looked like a pain in the ass there too,
a little bit. It's a little
high, you know. Well,
it's only about six inches
above the truck. Not too bad.
When you think about hole,
you get a whole tent in there.
But if someone's going to climb up
that ladder, at least you can hear it.
You know,
I think if you've got a tent out and a
bear comes and gets you and your tent,
the statistical probability of that,
it's so small that it was just bad timing.
It's my peer time. Why wonder if they
had, I wonder if they had a, an open tent.
I have to ask where know how old
that kid got bit in the head.
I mean especially in Alaska,
I spent a lot of time up there
this year and it's so wet.
You have that 10 open most of the time
just to kind of keep air flowing and keep
everything more dry. It seems like I
do. At least you leave it open. I leave,
I close the vest. You Boo. But I leave
a lot of the tent. Yeah. Open, you know,
vent it.
Cause I think a lot of people just close
themselves in there and then your body
creates sweat and steam and then nothing
ever dries out when you, uh, there's,
there's all these different
moves now to try to, or uh,
movements now to try to hike and
camp out as lightly as possible,
like super light packs. Some guys
don't even bring their own water,
they just bring filters so they can felt
fine water and filtered along the way.
And then it sort of adds to the element,
like you're living almost off the land,
like really close to off the land.
And I know you've done hunts where you
literally did, you didn't bring any food.
Like there was some of your episodes
where you were starving to death on TV.
Yeah. Um, yeah I, I like to go
light sometimes at my own detriment.
Um, I think you know, there, there's
times where, you know, I think,
well there, there's uh, they always
say like Hump, like you're hungry. Mm.
And I've, I've done, I've done some
research on things and your, your physio,
your physiology changes.
There's a lot of animals that
only hunt when they're hungry. Um,
there's some that just always hunt.
Um,
but or like not hungry but literally
starving. But you sense more your,
your sense of smell is heightened.
I think you do like they call
it more exploratory sniffing,
but you're just taking in more senses
and dissecting everything a little bit
more. Cause everything's sort of
ramped up because you need the sources.
You're hungry.
So when you walk into a place,
if you walk into a grocery store or like
a restaurant or you're walking down the
street and you're really hungry,
you'll smell the Turkey roasting a lot
further away than you would if you are on
a completely full
stomach because it's not,
your brain is not searching for food at
that point. Yeah. My wife always says,
don't go grocery shopping. Hungry,
hungry. You want to Frickin,
when you walk through the bread aisle,
when you're hungry, you smell the bread.
You don't at any other thing.
You're like, I need bread. So true.
You never smell it when you're
full. That's so true. I wonder,
so it physiologically, are there
changes that are going on? Yeah.
You're doing more exploratory. Well
you're, you're smelling more times,
your brain's processing what's coming
in because it's looking for food.
So this is actually a measurable
fact. Wow. That makes,
it makes sense that
it's designed like that.
And it also makes sense that maybe your,
your,
your senses would be heightened and you'd
be like less prone to fuck around and
really get down to business. Yeah.
But I mean a lot of times yeah,
as far as going back country type,
you can't carry everything you
need most times seen. Yeah.
You need to drink water is there,
you need to,
I mean I'll bring as much food
as I can on a normal trip,
but a lot of times I made,
you know,
if you can find something also to eat
or bring them catch fish or whatever,
it just aids and you being
able to stay out there longer.
You just have to rely on the ability
to do that. And when you don't,
like there was that one trip that
you did on solo hunter where you a,
I think it was a mule
deer hunt. Yup. In Nevada.
And you basically were
starving to death on TV. Yeah.
And then part of that was I
had food with me on that one,
but I was burning way more calories than
I was taking in because you're hiking
in the high country and just going in,
it was rough,
steep stuff and I didn't
bring enough food,
but I also wasn't finding any deer so
I just kept staying on and didn't have
enough food. And then eventually
I found a deer. I was like, fine.
When you ate that day or was that the
best tasting thing you've ever eaten in
your life? That was good. I think ate
the heart. Raw it you're like, yeah.
All you bit into it on
this show. Yeah. Um,
like when you did the black bear
episode, what did you do for that? Uh,
that was forging, so, oh, so he did it
all. Foraging, foraging, just kind of,
I wouldn't call it a survival episode
cause I just think that's kind of,
it's hard to it.
I've,
I've decided the only real way to do
a survival type show would be to film
yourself. And that's the truth
because like Les Stroud does. Yeah.
And I think like maybe that, I don't know
if you've seen naked and afraid. Yes.
I think that ones like the way they
have it set up, it could be sued.
It's super legit in my opinion.
But I think also like when you're
trying to do is film a survival show.
You're also filming a TV show.
So you need to do certain
things for filming that are
detracting from surviving.
So you may not be dedicating
100% attention to finding
food and other things I
guess. But yeah, I didn't bring
any food or anything with me.
So for three days I foraged to like a
bare wood and I wasn't intending to hunt
anything. I was just foraging and can be
like, is this a hunting show? Is this a,
well it's not really a hunting shows,
but it's also,
I wanted to see what lesson I learned
from that and I learned a pretty sweet
lesson as far as why
humans possibly needed to hunt.
You know,
as far as the sucks. Yeah. Well it,
yeah it devotes so much
time and you're eating,
I call them the bitter leafy Greens,
just sticks and twigs and it tastes
like shit, you know, was much calories.
Can you get out of that
though? Not that much. I,
I mean you,
you can get enough enter what I call it
is like getting enough energy to go out
hunting cause you at some point
are going to want a
substantial meal and even just,
I mean obviously like three days
here and can you could even fast for,
you know, you don't need
that food. But when you're,
when you're working and doing things
like if you were going out hunting, yeah,
you're burning a lot of calories to try
to get a bigger score that you can have
for a longer period of time
where I wasn't working,
just kind of gathered constantly
gathering little salads,
like little salads with no dressing like
you would so monotonies through that so
quick to your body would just like light
that on fire at some point when you're
eating.
I mean like real bitter stuff like
Chicory and Daniel Lyons and crap and it's
just so bitter.
It's like I'll just go hungry.
Just longing for some Newman's own
salad dressing. It's something cook it.
I was like,
this slug would probably be better now
when you ate the slug and you said that
there was a worm that you could
possibly get the bleeding and warm.
I get know about that beforehand.
Yeah.
Apparently I've done a lot
of things that I find out.
I like to do things and
then research afterwards.
It's kind of like trial by fire.
I've done a lot of bullets,
but I guess I think they eat rat
shit that has something in it.
Who Does bears do? Slugs. Oh, slugs do.
Oh, SPEC slugs eat ratchet. And then that,
that's somehow or another region,
but it'd be in their intestines.
So I know that enough to not eat
intestines have a lot of things.
I didn't even know slugs hadn't test
since. I thought they were just a slug.
And I've got my whole little
soul tracks going on. Yeah.
Well I've Fed, uh, my,
my chickens love snails.
They'll fuck a snail up, man.
They find a snail. My chickens
are funny, man. They'll,
they'll stand by. Like if
I'll, I'll pick up a rock. No,
they'll wait around the rock and I'll
lift up the rock and they fucking swarm
under the rock looking to
get at whatever's in there.
Like they know now they've,
their brains are so small,
they're so stupid.
But they know now that when I go near
a rock, I'm gonna pick it up for them.
And they noticed some shit underneath
that rock that go after it.
But when they see a snail, they'll
fucking fight over it. They'll,
they'll check each other out of
the way. And Jack that snail. Yeah,
they're [inaudible] snails.
Snails are a lot better than
slugs and worn seal of approval.
But you ate everything raw. You
didn't try to cook anything, did you?
You'll have to watch the episode.
I eat something that might
even make fear factor really.
But it was good. I was like, whoa. Hey,
this is delicious. Now what about, um,
I saw the otter episode and you held
your breath for like four minutes, right?
A little over four minutes. That's crazy.
I did it in this studio. I had that guy,
the iceman, Wim Hoff.
We've heard of that guy.
He's the guy that summited Everest
in his shorts with no shirt on.
Yeah.
Well the ice shoes on.
He ran a half marathon in Finland at
30 below zero weather with no shoes and
shorts with no shirt on. Yeah. He's
got this crazy breathing method.
It's wild breathing
method and he's just,
he's got 26 I believe,
world records for in endurance and cold
and the ability to withstand cold swam,
supposed to swim 50 yards under
the ice to this hole in Antarctica.
And uh, when was it Antarctica,
wherever it was somewhere cold as fuck.
We swam under ice anyway.
It was so cold.
The water was so cold that his eyeballs
froze and he couldn't see so he couldn't
find where the whole is
to pop up at 50 yards in.
So he swam back and forth, say wound
up swimming. The actual distance,
there's over a hundred yards underwater.
It's crazy with one breath. Yeah.
It was the same cause holding,
holding your breath and cold water's
super hard. It's really hard.
That's one of the things
we found on a fear factor.
He would put these people in cold
water and make them do these stunts.
As soon as you get in there,
your start shivering. Yeah.
Using up your oxygen. Have
you, have you, you should try.
Have you ever tried the
long breath hold thing?
The longest I've ever held.
It was on the show.
Two minutes and 30 seconds
or something like that.
That's like that. That's not you and a
half minute threshold. Once you, it's,
it's a crazy experience because everybody
can hold their breath for that for
five minutes I think. Yeah.
Well you did it the first time.
You only did it for a couple of minutes.
Right?
We'll just like straight out of the gate.
No practice. Just a minute and a half.
And then,
yeah,
and by the end of the few hours I was
holding my breath for over four minutes
and this was just someone teaching
you a method. We'll really,
it's just a mental thing.
Get over.
It was just knowing that you aren't
going to die when your body is screaming
that you are, uh, it's a
weird, but once you break the,
once you break through that
threshold, you're like, ah.
And even when I got up, I was thinking to
myself, I could have gone longer. Really?
Yeah.
Because he was there in,
the first thing they teach you is like
when you're with a a dive buddy or
whatever these things, he's like, breathe.
The first thing he tells you his breathe
because you get up and you forget to
breathe like everybody blacks out at
the surface because it's almost like you
figure it out.
You really don't need air.
It's just the mental aspect of thinking
that you do. It's really weird. And,
and they kind of explained
the whole stages of your,
your body that you'll go through and
they know when you actually do need to
breathe. And so we, it's a, it's
like the coolest feeling though.
When you get up, you're like, wow,
it's a mental thing and a physical
thing and it's a cool feeling. Well,
it's a primal terror.
Yeah.
Not having any air as a primal
terrorist. Yeah. It's makes people panic,
you know? And when you're
a, when you're exhausted,
that's one of the things that
MMA fighters do to each other.
When they're exhausted though,
they'll cover the other guy's
mouth and nose and it's,
it's a legal tactic and you'll see it
like in grappling matches where guys will
have a guy,
I'll have a guys back in and tried to
choke him and he'll cover his whole cover,
his mouth and his and his nose.
She's a
garlic.
And when you try to move that guy's hand,
that's when will choke you
because you're exposing your neck.
Like you might be defending your neck
and then they just cover your mouth hall
and then you have to,
you have to open up a little to try
to stop the covering your mouth.
And that's when they get an arm on
doing neck. Once you start to panic,
you use up all that had essential oxygen.
Well,
Wim Hof has held his breath for
seven minutes and I was like,
Jesus Christ just sitting here. He would
just hold it for seven minutes. Yeah,
I'd say hold it for seven minutes
underwater. I think too. Yeah.
There's people that can go 12 plus.
Well didn't David Blaine wins did make
some world record? I think so. Yeah.
And what he did. He pack he lung
packed with pure oxygen. Yeah,
that's what I heard. Yeah. Yeah.
He like breathe in from a tank
or something like that. Right.
And then it allows you to hold
it much longer, I guess. Yeah,
but still that first like,
well if you did two and a half minutes,
that first tooth first minute
feels like forever. Yeah.
I probably a Deb going a little longer,
but I was starting to panic. Yeah,
you just get,
I would,
the other thing though is to
initiate the Mammalian dive reflex.
You need to like splash
your face with water.
You need to kind of like lower your heart
rate, kind of almost meditation style,
lower your heart rate, get into a
place where your body's ready for it.
That's what they call it. 1
million dive reflex. The same.
It's the same reflex that whales and
all aquatic mammals use to hold their
breath and humans have the exact
same dive reflex that whales.
Have you ever heard the
theory of the aquatic ape? Mm,
no.
It's a really fascinating theory about
human beings that they believe that human
beings evolved around water.
And that's why our babies are so
fat because, uh, like a champ,
baby chimp babies or sinewy,
they come out of the gate like yoked
chimp babies already fucking shredded,
you know, and our babies are so fat.
And the idea is that, uh, our babies,
like if you take a chimp baby
and you throw it in the water,
apparently the little fucker will drown.
But if you take a human baby
and he throw it in the water,
the baby will hold its breath, right?
Yeah. That's that Mammalian dive reflex.
We automatically know how to hold their
breath. So there's that general swim.
Now that's where it came from that we
like literally evolved to be around water
and we're around water,
which kind of almost makes sense when
you think about the fact that the high
population centers are
always around ports.
We're all always around water and that's
how we've been traveling back and forth
for eons. Well, there's a lot of food
underwater as well. Now, what do you,
when you, uh, did the otter
episode, what did you try,
did you try to eat shit that
you found or did, did uh,
open water spear phishing thing.
Oh, that's right. Yeah. Yeah.
Spear phishing is like not fishing.
It's like underwater hunting. Yeah.
That's cool. It's fun. I've, I've
done it before and once I did this,
like learning from a guy who
really knows what he's doing,
I realized that everything I had done in
the past probably should have killed me.
The top 10 things not to do. I did. I
was like, what? What are those things?
Let your air out. I would like as I
would swim up and I would, I would go,
I would dive pretty deep without anybody
without a buddy and just all kinds of
stupid stuff.
So did you do the proper calculations?
Like Bordain was telling
me he loves a scuba diving,
but he said one of the hardest
things was learning the calculations.
Like you've been this deep for this long,
so you have to go to this area and
wait and then go to that area and wait.
Like there's like calculations that you
have to do to make sure you don't get
the bends. You don't do that. Um, when
you take a breath from the surface,
because when you're scuba diving,
you're breathing compressed air, right?
So as you go different depths in the
water, the pressure changes on your body.
So the amount of oxygen in that space
changes. So if you take a breath,
like if you dove down, took a breath
from compressed air and wind up,
your lungs would explode, you'd be dead.
Whoa. That's why when you free dive,
it's one breath.
You can't,
you can't be down there and go emergency
sipping on oxygen and then shoot up to
the surface cause you'll float right
up to the top and explode. Oh Wow.
So you got to,
if you take it from the surface,
your lungs change with the space of air,
if that makes sense.
That does make sense. So as you
dive deeper, your lungs compact,
but what that does is it puts
the same amount of oxygen,
a smaller amount of space.
So it's almost like you feel
you have more breath I guess,
but you feel the pressure and then
as you go up, your lungs expand.
So it kind of feels,
so you can kind of play with your breath
hold based on the depths that you're at.
I've never been in deep water before,
but I would imagine like the
pressure must feel really freaky.
Like if you're like, what does it,
what does it feel like on your body?
It just feels like, yeah, it
feels heavy. Heavy pressure. Yeah.
Wow. And, and the weight of your,
so your buoyancy changes as well.
So it depends how deep your diving.
But like I was waited for 33 feet,
so at 33 feet I would float
to the top below 33 feet sink.
Oh, so, so, so the first
33 feet you kick down,
you're kicking harder because you're
floating, right. Once you get past that,
you can slowly kick because you know,
to change the amount of energy you're
doing and you can keep going down, down,
down.
But because as you're sinking and then
when you come back up you need to kick
hard and then once you hit 33 feet,
you pretty much just float to the surface.
So if you blacked out, as long as you're
above 33 feet, you'll pop back up. Wow.
So on your way up, because most of
the blackouts happen at the top,
what kind of crazy assholes figured out
how town they're sticking to the tank
connected to. I mean when did
they first start doing that?
When did scuba dive in first
start getting, not sure.
I know they used to pump it from the
surface and the big helmets, you know?
Oh that's right. Yeah. I
said it'd be on the top.
I remember watching videos about those
fucking things wants to leak like crazy
too.
They probably SAP use tree SAP and shit.
Just see love suit
take drop you in like a rock.
The first time somebody got
the Benz it probably like,
what's wrong with this pussy?
Oh yeah.
They were just making it
up as they went along,
but free diving is not the same issues.
Right.
You could take a deep breath and you can
go as deep as you want and come back up
as quick as you want. Right? Yup. No, no
speed. And that's how you did it. Yeah.
So that seems to me like
super risky though, right?
Like if you're down there and you're,
you're running out of air,
it's gotta be, um, no, I don't
know. I mean it could be,
I guess if it's, I think it's like
anything if you do it safely, right? Yeah.
It's kind of unnerving when you dive down.
You look up and just like you're really
deep and you're holding your breath,
holding your breath. But if you
start to panic, you're gonna,
it's counterproductive.
You're going to use up your,
so when you feel like you're out there
and you start panicking and then you're
out, you're going to be out
of here faster. Yeah. Now
when you, when you do it,
dive down and he goes deep as you
can and then your spear fishing.
Do you have like a watch on the
tells you like where you're at?
Are you just going based on I can hang
in here for like another 30 seconds and I
got it
ended up pretty much.
And you can like,
you could drop a line down that you
could almost see like dive by aline has
markings on it. Yes. I mean I'm
by no means a dive expert. Right.
But I mean it's one thing that I,
I do enjoy doing it.
It seems awesome. Yeah. Now,
um, when you do do it though,
like what is the longest time you've ever,
I mean you held your breath for
four minutes was a long time.
You ever held your breath
while you were free diving and
spearfishing? Probably two
minutes. Two minutes. Yeah.
It's about half cause you can go,
well you would do is like go down say
40 feet and just hang for a minute and
then back up. You know,
it's like 30 seconds down,
minute back up to the surface. So you go
into like a riff or something like that?
Yeah. Or were you just like for that
episode we were in open ocean. Most.
Everything I've done before was fishing
around like spear fishing around reefs.
But this was open ocean.
Just like that's kind of weird cause
you're kicking down. There's no bottom,
just blue water. You see a giant sharks
from black. He saw sharks. Yeah. Oh God.
And then, but then you, you get there,
you hang and you see this whole school
of fish and then they come up to you like
big school, big fish. I mean
these are 40 pound fish.
There's a video that somebody sent me from
South Africa. These guys, South Africa,
maybe Australia, I'm not sure.
I think it was Australia.
Now let me think about these guys caught
a Marlin and they're bringing in the
Marlin and a shark. Malls. It
like feet from the boat like six,
seven feet from the bulk,
cuts it in half and all they pull up
as the fin or the, uh, the nose. Those,
what they call it shark, what
did they call the, the sword,
the sword or whatever it is.
Everything from the Gills back has gone,
but it was a big shark. It was a
great white, just severed half smashed
it. It's like fuck that.
Fuck all that. Yeah.
They throw a propane tank in there
and try to shoot it with a 30 yes.
Great movie. Now when you saw the big
shark, did you freak out at all? No.
And it was gone as quick as it appeared.
Oh it was,
it was pretty cool though because um,
it w I needed a break after a while
because it's just kind of starting to get
seasick and I got on the boat and we had
Dan Dodi through aligning and caught a
fish and he's fighting this fish is like
sweet and then all of a sudden his rod
just doubles over, fishes gone. That
shark just hammered it. Took it.
Oh my God. It's pretty cool. That is
cool. And then the shark was gone.
I mean we only saw it briefly. I don't
even remember what kind it was. Fuck.
But I mean it eight a 40 pound fish.
Where were you guys again
when you're efficient? Gulf
of Mexico. Off Florida. Yeah.
There's a lot of fish down
there in the law. Sharks. It
was cool. Uh, the whole, uh,
west coast to California, like down
through Mexico. A lot of sharks.
Apparently there's a breeding
area that's around San Francisco,
like San Francisco, the great
whites. They breed up there. Hmm.
Which is very unnerving.
Yeah. Right outside of a city,
the biggest monster Predator on the
planet between San Francisco and Alcatraz.
Yeah. Yeah. Right there. Yeah.
Where people are swimming. Yeah.
That's where they breed.
Fuck that.
Fuck all that you have you seen it? I'm
sure you've had to have seen that video.
I just recently saw it though.
I'm kind of outdated. But uh,
the surf competition where the dude, the
shirt grabs. That's pretty cool. Yeah.
Crazy. We'll explain it
and explain what happened.
[inaudible] he's paddling
in a surf competition.
Then all of a sudden the guy just,
he just went under, right. Sharp,
grabbed somehow went for the board and
got his leash and it was funny cause the
announcers had no clue what was going on.
They were just kinda talking normal.
It'd be like you announcing UFC and a
bear coming in and eating the dude and
just continuing on like, oh,
something strange is going on.
And Nate Diaz has disappeared from
the octagon. Yeah. What about,
um, there was one that you did
that was a Golden Eagle one.
What did you do with that one? Uh, we,
we looked at the way that the eagle
uses vision and I mean they can see prey
animals from up to two miles away,
which is insane.
I've heard that about bald eagles in
Alaska that they can see fish on the water
fish that are coming up on the surface.
They could see for miles. Yeah.
They say that eagles have,
well, even as they're flying,
they can see things so much faster.
It's almost like if you explain a
camera the way it has frame rates,
you can change the frame rate. If a
camera's how many frames per second? Well,
we have essentially the same thing in
our brain of how many images we can see
per second. So something's moving
real fast. We can't see it.
Where's the Eagle as its flying,
it sees more images at,
plus they have two centers of focus in
their eyes so they can focus in near and
far simultaneously.
Whereas our eyes change,
we look at our hands and everything else
is blurry and we look at the wall and
our hands are blurry, but they can focus
on two things at the exact same time.
So they're looking at it like, um,
like, like a video camera. Yeah.
Instead of like a film camera or a video
camera. This might be too technical,
but a video camera with a high f stop.
That means that like it's,
but it's actually different. Like the
more light, less light you let in,
the more things are in focus.
But they have two centers of focus
where our eyes just have one. Huh.
Wow.
Yeah.
But then we related that to using optics
and being able to sit up on a mountain
top and spot animals from two
plus miles away consistently.
Yeah. That's the one thing that animals
haven't figured out yet. Optics. Yeah.
Well just if you could get
an eagle pair of binoculars.
Yeah. Well, the Eagle, yeah,
it's got the optics built into its head.
I wonder if they mean they can
spot things from miles away,
but I mean I wonder if they
have like a magnified vision.
Yeah, they do. They did. Yeah. It's
just like looking through optics.
I mean they can spot things. Their
visions, it's hard to quantify it as,
cause we,
we use numbers with our optics like eight
times or they say they say an antelope
has like eight power, binocular vision.
See, throw up your eight carbon oculars.
And it was like what an analyst.
But they also obviously can see right in
front of them when they're eating their
foods. So it's different. So
they can see as they're flying,
they can look like on the hill two miles
away and right below him it's such a
fast rate that they can spot things.
They,
they kind of have a search image in their
head of what an animal looks like and
then when they see it,
the key on it and fly that direction.
That's one of the more fascinating things
about vision is that so many different
animals have different kinds of vintage
vision that of simultaneously evolved.
Yeah. The octopus, which is another
animal that you study. Cat Hands Down,
coolest animal on the planet.
Really?
I don't even know if it's from this
planet now after release. So weird.
Okay. Their vision, they
don't see the octopus.
The one thing I was looking as
their ability to camouflage,
and I don't think a lot of people realize
that's probably the most amazing thing
about the octopus. If you can find
a video of octopus, they can shape,
shift and change their
color and shape instantly.
Have you ever seen that,
oh,
this is going to blow your mind yet we
don't know how with all of our technology,
we cannot replicate it and
we don't know how they do it,
but they have chromatophores
in their skin,
which is like pigment cells and they
can change the color of their skin,
but because they have no bones,
they can also adjust the
shape instantaneously to
match whatever's around them.
Like coral. Yeah. Well
they can, whatever it is,
like multiple colors and they
can match it identically.
Yet they don't see color,
but they can match the color identically.
So they almost feel like,
like we don't know how this works,
but there is a running theory that they
somehow see through their skin that we
don't understand. It's, you got
to see these videos. There's,
there's a bunch of videos of just
octopus camouflaging themselves. They'll,
there's one clip that we use in the show
where it like goes up to this rock in
instantly morphs itself.
It's, it's, it's a,
it's a live action cloaking
mechanism. Crazy. There's live,
that's a great way of
describing this is this one. Um,
I'll have a tough time showing it
to the audience because you took,
might take it down, but Gotcha.
Okay. Well let's just show it to us.
We'll show it so we won't put it on
the, well, what's the name of this?
So for people. Okay. Shape shifting
octopus. Okay. So we'll get, uh,
we'll, we'll look at it and people
and Youtube go fuck yourself.
Slow motion right now. So it was
a slow motion and it's, Oh my God,
whoa. Even see that octopus. Whoa.
What the fuck man?
And people don't really know that they do.
That well describes.
Amazing.
Describe what we're looking at
for people that can't see this.
The octopus goes to a rock that
has multiple textures on it.
I would say there's some kelp and some
or some, some kind of plant materials.
A Brown rock.
It changes its skin to match
probably three where you see three,
four colors in there. Well that's
not even in the texture that that,
that's a plant. It's a plant.
So it became that algae.
Exactly. That's fucking insane. I
need to see that again. That isn't,
I know I did. There's a, they do it
instantaneously to, if there's like a,
there's some videos of it where it does
it. So it's so fast. Within a second.
It changes the way they had
to play it in slow motion.
So that right there we're looking
at an octopus. Yeah. That is insane.
That's insane. That is fucking
insane. That is a goddamn alien.
And then he shoots watching Fox appears.
Yeah.
So he follows it and then
it does it again. Boom,
clunk down. Cause they're now, now
if you were looking down on it,
it's matching the,
the spots and everything in the ground.
That is insane.
So now it's a slow motion version of it.
I want to see the fast motion version
of it again cause it doesn't even make
sense. But the slow motion version
is really cool too. Like right.
We're looking at this thing and I
swear it has all the bumps of allergy.
It looks like the Predator like from
the movie when it becomes the octopus of
cloaking mechanism,
we can't think about all the,
that's what I was talking about earlier.
As far as camouflage goes,
we put so much science into
camouflage and this is,
this is the Ed,
all Beal of camouflage.
If we could figure that out as
far as any application for it,
that's what we aspire to. And yet with all
of our technology, I hopped in a plane,
flew all this way
while I was,
you know,
emailing someone across the
country simultaneously. Yet.
We can't figure out how the
octopus does that. I have no idea.
I had no idea because I mean,
we're not exaggerating this folks,
if you're watching this or if you're
listening, you really have to watch this.
I've never seen this before.
Isn't it crazy? So we, we,
so one of the things is like,
we brought this to light in the show
is this is the fact that people should
learn about the octopus and it's not like
a thing it does every once in a while.
It does it constantly. It's always
doing that. Look at this one. Whoa.
And every species of octopus
fucking colors, man. Crazy.
This is incredible. The
shapes, it's amazing.
Well,
there's so follow Jesus Christ.
They just turns into some stripe. The
also make themselves look like another,
like almost looked like a predator.
So if something bigger is coming at them,
they'll boom flash and make like an I and
crazy stuff to, to protect themselves.
Wow. I almost feel bad eating them,
but they're my favorite Sushi. Yeah.
I don't really enjoy them. That's
it's okay. They're cool. They,
they live in a very short lives as
well and their, their brain capacity,
they advance so fast.
An octopus lives about two years.
That's it.
Even these giant Pacific octopus maybe
I get well like I just think they live,
I can't remember exactly three, four
years maybe tops. That's it. Yeah,
and then but they,
they learn rapidly like they can figure
out what the fuck is that as an octopus,
what the fuck is that?
It's,
it looks like a bear with an allergy suit
on and it's running on two legs while
looking like a stick
while looking like some,
some piece of floating coral or or some,
some plant matter. That is insane.
I literally had no idea. Yeah,
that's the most,
that's probably one of the most amazing
things I discovered while doing this
shit or just like did you
not to this capacity and I'm thinking
to myself like, how did I not know?
I feel like I know a decent amount
about a lot of things there.
There should be,
I wish I could find the,
I wish we had that
episode going right now.
It's going to air here in a few
weeks. Well when it airs, um,
texts me like when that one's
going to hear the next day we'll,
we'll play some clips from and if we can,
you guys won't pull us off you cube,
right?
Nah,
you can do whatever you want this off
youtube that I really had no idea.
Look, click at that man. I thought
they just became like the color.
I didn't know that they could
assume EIP and everything.
The texture of algae and when we're
talking about the texture of algae,
we're not exaggerating.
I mean it looks like leaves and it
goes to the scene and then goes back.
Look at the speed that it changes
instantaneous God instant and the really
fucking smart too. That's the other
weird. So we were, we were in the,
this wasn't the show so I don't mind
talking about it because there is this one
octopus and we had, we were just kind
of like messing with them. The graph,
you know, there's suckers are pretty
strong and on you. And we had this,
we would use these little pieces of fish
and there's this thing that was like a
wand where we could kind of lure it out.
Well it had figured out the fish was
sitting up on the top of the tank.
So it like distracted us by grabbing
the wand and as we're doing this arm
reaches up, grabs the whole dish and
brings it in. It's like, screw you guys,
I'm not playing your game anymore. It
was so weird, like smarter than I was.
Well, you've heard about the um,
the fish tank that was missing.
The guy was missing like
some real expensive tropical
fish and he had two fish
tanks across from each other and they set
up a camera and he watched the octopus
climb out of one tank, go across
the floor, climb up the other tank,
lift up the lid, climbing
side, jack the fish, eat it,
climb back out of the tank, go across the
floor again, back into his tank. Yeah.
The, the Denver Aquarium where
we did this episode at, uh,
had locks on the octopus tank top.
Padlocks get that man.
It makes you wonder like what kind of
life is out there in the universe if this
is on our own planet and that is an alien.
It's weird and I've,
I've heard they configure it, if
you put it off, should look at this
dude,
if you saw that on the ground,
if something just popped up like that
on the ground and looked like that,
you'd say, Oh, this is obviously some
sort of a poisonous fucking monster.
I got to run away from this thing.
And they'll change based on
thinking predators are after him.
And it looks like a, a poison.
It's moray eel right there.
It's like white or
black and white stripes.
And then the fact that it can go from
black and white stripes to all tan and
looking like a piece of coral
to green and look like algae.
It's pretty fucked up. Fuck.
Look at that. The crabs like,
hey bitch puffing his body up
to look bigger. Yeah, it's,
well it's going to eat that crap so
it's going to do the crap knows it too.
That's the fucked up thing about it.
They'll jack crabs and lobsters and
shit and they just engulf them and then
inside of them they have this
beak. Yeah. Have you seen the um,
the evidence of the cracking that
they found the fossil evidence? No.
Pull that shit up, Jamie.
They recently discovered,
I think within the last five or six
years they discovered these fossilized a
suction cups from an enormous octopus.
And they think that at one point in time,
the idea of the crackin like that was
like always a mythological creature.
If there was some enormous octopus that
would take out boats and shit and kill
people, they think there really was
something that was that big. Now, well,
there's [inaudible] species of like even
giant squid that we've never actually
seen alive. Maybe now we have, but believe
we've seen a few of them now, but yeah,
but they're really recently,
like within the last decade,
like,
look at that.
They think this is from
a 100 foot long octopus.
It's a fossil. You can imagine a 100 foot
octopus that it's as smart as they are.
They would kind of tap one side of the
boat is you go look over the there.
So yeah, I'm sure it's crazy. Well they
probably Jack people that have boats,
they probably really did.
If they found out they can eat people,
I mean look a person, especially
back then people were tiny, you know,
like the average Roman soldier I think
was only like five foot two or something
like that or five foot three.
There were people who were really a little
back then like the civil war and the
civil war. The average man that was
fighting the civil war, it was 130 pounds.
They were like tiny little people because
nobody, I need fucking food. Yeah.
They hadn't figured out,
probably hunting.
They weren't Ricky recreationally
working out either. There was no,
there was no, uh, you know, weight
gaining powder that you buy in GNC.
There's no one was doing squats and the
these fucking giant 100 foot octopus
probably with Jack. Those people. I mean,
it only makes sense. They would just,
why would they, they don't have
morals, you know the idea that, well,
the humans who are friends now,
it flipped that boat over.
You might be imagined just looking in
the water and seeing a 100 foot octopus.
I mean a 100 foot of octopus is many times
bigger than the room we're in, right?
Yeah. And they, they changed their
size to, they fill up, I mean
crazy room. We're in, man. How was the
door? Door to door here from here to here?
How big is this place? I wonder
would it be 20 feet? 20 feet,
maybe write five times bigger than that.
I'll fucking octopus.
That's crazy. Jesus. Jamie, is
that just it's head or it's like,
it's whole body tip to tip tip to ahead
as they found it in Nevada too. Oh,
Jesus.
Like the Berlin thesaurus area.
So probably if they found it in Nevada,
that means Nevada was probably
underwater. Just like, uh,
parts of Montana that they keep finding
great base and like it was the largest
lake in North America. Look
at that man. Look at that.
It cathar how'd he say that?
He is sore state park in Nevada may be
a part of the beak of an ancient giant
cephalopod such as an octopus or squid.
What I used to go there,
look around as a kid.
He'd find the cool stuff. You okay.
So this was 2013 they found this.
So it makes it, that's what I
was reading this thing about. Um,
it was on dig and you know,
dig is a great a website,
like a portal to a bunch of
other like really cool articles.
And it had one of them where they were
saying that we'll never find all the
dinosaurs because of the
nature of gathering fossils,
fossils they find apparently CV can find
that article because I don't want to
misquote it,
but I think they were saying that they
find two new species of dinosaur a month.
Wow. Yeah. Yeah. Like what?
So I think the name of the article is
you will never find all the dinosaurs,
but uh, I think that was one of the
things that they were saying was there.
So many dinosaurs we're finding,
but the nature of a fossil
being discovered like,
or created rather like most when we die,
most likely we will not be fossils.
We'll just rot and then we'll get eaten
by bacteria or whatever and rodents and
whoever the fuck he eats our bones.
And that'll be the end of it.
Like if you leave, I mean, I'm sure many
times you've stumbled across some bones,
uh, out in the woods. There
were some animal and you know,
what you're saying is just like what
remains and if you came back in 10 years,
that'll be gone too. Yeah, well
think about a million years.
Think about 10 million years now.
Think about 65 million years.
The last time we had dinosaurs,
now think about 250 million years.
It was another extinction event.
So look at that.
So yeah, cc, if you find the, um, what,
what the number is because
if you scroll down,
they were talking about it was
what part of the article was, um,
how often they find,
this is not the same article,
although it has the same. Um, just I
think it's the same, uh, you know, the,
it might've been an
aggregate thing where they,
they took it from one scientific study
and made a bunch of articles about the,
uh, w with the same title, but
they, they don't know. They don't,
they don't know how many a
good dinosaurs they were.
They don't know what the
fuck they all looked like.
It's probably a shitload of them that
everybody ate and they can't find any
fossils that like,
like the chickens of the dinosaur world.
Like good luck finding them the
bottom of the food chain. Well,
that's why it's amazing to me when they
find something like that hobbit person,
you know, that thing that they
found in the island of Flores.
Do you know about all that?
I heard about it.
It was 13,000 years ago was
the mo the, the closest, uh,
one of the most recent one rather.
And it was a tiny little human type thing
that was like three feet tall when it
was fully grown and it was
like humanoid and it would,
it was smaller brain than a
human, but yeah, like a Hobbit,
but it wasn't like, uh, like door FISM
you know, now. Well that was, that was a,
there was a debate about that, but then
they found enough fossils are, they said,
nope, this is a totally different thing.
They, at first they were saying, you know,
first I think the first,
first uh, discovery,
they were saying this is a new species,
but they were pretty cautious about
it and they were saying, well,
it might be someone that has
some sort of a weird disease.
Then they found a bunch of them and
then there's some speculation that they
believe they're wiped out by people
because they were cannibalizing people.
They were, they were coming after
people and people coming after them.
And it's a war between the US.
Yeah. Little hobbits at eat people.
I don't know if they know about
that might be all horse shit though.
That might be just total speculation. I
would speculate too. Why not. Exactly,
but I mean exactly like what you're
talking about with the giant crack and the
giant octopus. Of course it would
eat people. Everything we do, people,
we have this weird idea because we
live in cities and like, you know,
we think of hippos as being some thing
with a Tutu on and a fucking bow and it's
hair. Well, they don't want to
eat us well of course they do.
They want to eat everything they can eat.
If they can eat you,
they definitely want to eat you.
They don't not want to eat you because
you have a beard and you have an iPhone.
You know the ones that
could really inflict damage
though for some reason don't
eat the one I'm most scared
about. Killer whales. Yeah,
there they are so smart.
If they decided to just all
of a sudden gang up on humans,
we would be at such a loss.
We would never go in the ocean again.
We'd be fog as smart.
As long as Netflix stays out of the
ocean and they watch a black blackfish,
we're safe. But as soon as they find out
what happened at the end of that movie,
it's so fucking done.
Yeah,
well it's so crazy that we still keep
them in captivity because we've always
kept them in captivity because if we
didn't ever have them captive and we
discovered them in the ocean,
these super intelligent creatures,
and we found out about their capabilities,
we found out about their language,
the fact they have dialects,
the fact they live in these
complex ordered societies,
they stay with the same pod for life.
They have family like deep connect
connections with these other orchids that
they consider their family.
I mean, we just steal them.
Steelman stick them in a fish,
communicate across the oceans through
essentially whale internet. Yeah.
That's not crazy.
And then we're assholes.
We stick them in a tank and fat people
eat cotton candy and stare at him.
Make it job lawyer.
This is a rip off.
We're assholes. We're, we're
fucking really shitty animals too.
To do that to Wales. And to killer
whales and it's really shitty. Yeah.
Well there was a, um, a thing that
a, I was listening to this Ted talk,
whether they were talking about
a sustainable organisms and um,
that a lot of the logic that we apply
to a hunting and trapping some organisms
thinking that we're going to help the
food chain out doesn't wind up helping.
And one of them was whales that
the Japanese had made this idea.
They had this idea,
well if we a hunt,
a certain amount of whales will have
more fish and more krill because the
Japanese eat all these krill or the
whales rather eat all these krill.
And if we hunt the whales, it'll help
the krill and the fish population.
But apparently that's not the case
because one of the reasons why there's so
much krill is because of the whales,
because the whales will let
loose these enormous shits.
They come up and just shit these
giant clouds of whale shit.
And algae grows from that.
And then the krill are attracted to the
algae and the krill eat the algae and
they, they, they, that's
what sustains them.
So when they started hunting the whales,
it actually lowered the population of
Krill and they ha they had to like put it
all together. That's a
crazy cycle. We didn't,
we never really know what we're
messing with. Think we know. So,
and that's the
thing. One of the things I, you know,
people might say that aren't into hunting,
well let's just leave it the way it was,
release all the wolves and then let
nature take care of itself. But that's,
it's an impossible,
it's an impossible thing because we've
already affected the landscape so much
that nothing,
I mean,
especially with non native species
and invasive plants and habitat,
deforestation and so many other things
that affect the thought of just like
letting me chair run itself
isn't even an option now.
And then you even look at it even further
and go like human hunters have been in
the equation since all of these
animals have been here. When,
when is the elk existed?
When humans haven't hunted it?
I don't know an answer to
that because there isn't one.
Well, no one knows the answer.
Yeah. To go past 10,000 years,
you'd have to go across the ice age.
Right? It's like, well,
the wolves were not the only predators
on North America since humans have been
here.
No.
Well, there was lions. Yeah.
You know, there was a kinds of,
we're going to bring back that we're
going to find that lion or find some DNA
from it and bring it back from extinction
that we don't even know why those
things went extinct. Nobody
bothered to write that down.
Oh, we did that. You know,
they know what nobody knows.
Even there's still debate as to
what happened to the woolly mammoth.
Some people still think
that it was humans.
There was some paper that was recently
published that was saying that there was
evidence that they were coming into estrus
younger and younger and that this was
because of hunting pressure. They believe
it was because of hunting pressure.
Could it be pure speculation
or predators as well?
Could be, but there was, there
was, it was pure speculation.
I mean mixed with some evidence,
but there's also some evidence that they
died in a giant mass extinction that
people like Randall Carlson of connected
to an asteroid will impact. Hmm.
And it was also a the same,
roughly the same time period
as the end of the ice age.
So they think that asteroidal impacts
slammed into the earth and, and not,
not just even global warming,
but just massive asteroidal
impacts all over the planet.
That there was some sort of a mass
extinction event worldwide that coincided
with the end of the ice age and the um,
the different errors of construction
methods for things like the old kingdom in
Egypt.
Um,
giant archeological digs like
go Beckley Tepi I'm having,
um, Randall Carlson and
this Guy Graham Hancock on,
they're going to be on
November 19th. And, uh,
Graham Hancock just wrote a book about
it called the magicians of the gods.
And he had an old one
that was a super popular,
it's sold like millions and millions of
copies called fingerprints of the gods
and that it's all basically asserting
back then he was trying to put the pieces
together and saying there are,
there's evidence of lost civilization.
And the way he described it,
he said,
we are essentially a
civilization with amnesia.
And that something happened
somewhere along the line.
And there's all this evidence of
these ancient structures that were,
that were made by advanced civilizations.
We really don't have any idea. Yeah.
It makes sense that natural disasters
did it. That there's some sort.
And then between the time of him
publishing that book and, uh,
Randall Carlson coming around and Randall
Carlson has been dedicated his whole
life to,
um,
researching asteroidal impacts and natural
disasters that are caused by a global
collisions. You know, things coming from
the sky and slamming into the earth.
But he's a,
he's a master Ma,
a giant database of factual
evidence that, uh, you know,
from other sources.
So it's not like him finding this stuff,
but it's like they're, they're discovered
things like [inaudible], which is a,
I think that I'm saying it right,
but it's a nuclear glass and all over
Europe and Asia and when they do those
core samples of the earth,
it cuts down around 12,000 years and that,
that nuclear glass happens
when they do nuclear tests,
but it also happens when
meteors impact the earth.
So they found this shit all over
the place at about 12,000 years,
which means there was just a fucking,
we were a shooting
gallery 12,000 years ago,
which is crazy to think like
we're so stable right now.
And then one meteor could ruin it and
then we get need to get really good with
those crossbows. Yeah, we've
got to make her own sticks.
And if you're living in a place like La,
you're going to have to
start fighting off people.
It was not going to be enough
food. No, there's enough people,
I guess we're going to have to start
eating them, eat the fat, slow on staying.
I'll stay in the mountains for that
one. Yeah, that's a good way. Like, Hey,
want to come down and do a
podcast during the apocalypse?
And I do it from my phone.
Well that's the other thing is
that once the power goes out,
we're not gonna have any
access to hard drives.
We're not going to have
any access to phones.
any access to the grid.
And if the grid is out for more than a
couple of years, it's going to stay out.
No one, you don't know how to fix
it. I don't know how to fix it.
I have no clue how the things I use work.
If we killed off 70% of the population,
we will be right back to the stone age.
Because the idea that those 30% that we
will be lucky enough to have people who
are so innovative and so educated that
they would be able to figure out how to
restart civilization.
No,
I'm still not sure that this
phone isn't somewhat magic.
Does anyone know how it works? Well, it is
magic, but so is that octopus, you know,
and they're both made by nature.
Yeah, I mean the phone is natural.
It just doesn't seem natural
because people made it.
But people are natural and people's
curiosity is natural and the phone is just
as natural as a fucking beaver dam.
It really is.
It's just some weird thing that a natural
creature has figured out how to do
when given enough time,
I'm
add enough source material, enough, uh,
enough sharing information with these
other weird monkeys and one monk,
he figures out a diode and the other
monkey figures out how to make glass and
this monkey figures out how to forge
metal and this monkey figures out how to
write code and they all get together.
And next thing you know,
you've got an iPhone. Yeah. That's
cool. Or You got an octopus, you know,
or you got an iPhone,
you can watch it. Yeah.
I mean that's the other thing about
the octopus is when all this shit has
happened on earth as far
as, um, there was, uh,
I want to say where it was.
I'm trying to remember when they've,
they've knocked it down to, they believe
that there was one point in time,
there was only a few thousand human beings
left on earth. And it wasn't long ago.
It was like 70,000 years ago.
And they've coincided it
with the explosion of one
of the world's great super
volcanoes and that it put the earth
into nuclear winter for a long period of
time. Most of the plants died.
Most of the animals died.
A giant percentage of the
population of human beings die.
And that's why there's so little bio
diversity amongst human beings are genetic
diversity amongst human beings. I
God, I can't remember where the, um,
Indonesia, I want to
say, I might be wrong,
where the super volcano
was that went off, but, um,
see if you could find that
super volcano 70,000 years ago,
killed off giant percentage
of the population.
Like all these preppers are ready for
the Yellowstone super volcano and it's
going to be,
but those guys are idiots because they
go on TV and everybody knows her and
Pasadena, then you're just going to
fucking go right to that guy's house.
Cause yet canned peaches and
bullets. Was it an Indonesia? Yeah.
So that,
that Super Volcano that erupted 70,000
years ago basically almost killed the
sauce. We got down to a few
thousand people and uh, yeah.
I mean we've got real close a few
times. Yeah. So 70,000 years ago,
I mean obviously people weren't
that advanced, but whatever.
They did know they got down to nothing.
You know,
you get down to 2000 people if
there was 2000 of us. Yeah. It's,
it's a giant episode of naked and afraid.
You're like,
God, I remember back when I was
your age, we actually had the, yeah,
I mean all the shit that we have
right now that we think of as cool,
like televisions and all that.
I have this,
I have the most retarded theory
when it comes to all this stuff.
I think that what we're essentially
doing is preparing to give birth to an
artificial life.
That's what I think.
I think that we're essentially like a
technological cocoon and then we're going
to become some sort of an electronic
artificially created butterfly.
That's what I think. I think that's
one of the reasons why we have these,
these inclinations towards materialism
because materialism feeds this desire to
constantly innovate and continue
to come up with newer, better shit.
Like we were talking about with
bows, like Cam Haynes, new bow.
He doesn't need a bow killed two fucking
grizzly bears. His boats perfect.
His bows perfect. But Hoyt has to
come up with a new bow every year.
So they will make a bowl that's
even better than that Bo.
And it'll come out next year or this year.
Um,
but this desire to constantly innovate
and look for the biggest, bestest,
newest,
greatest,
latest thing is what causes innovation
and that innovation will ultimately lead
to artificial life. I just think it's
inevitable. I think if you extrapolate,
look where everything's going,
there's no way around it.
And while that's going on, I'll
still be in the mountains. Yeah.
You'll be out there with
a beautiful, yeah. Oh,
there's robots that do stuff
while I'm still out here.
Meanwhile mean what's more fun?
You know,
it was it more fun to play
video games or El Con? Well,
I've done both and I'll tell you right
now, El Corning is way cooler. I think so.
And when it's over at first of all,
it's way cooler than a
video game and it's real.
And when it's over you get to eat.
Yeah. Yeah. It's a good deal. Do when,
when I shot that elk that's
out there in the lobby and um,
it was walking up the hill and I'm hiding
behind a tree at full draw for like 30
seconds as it's walking up the hill.
And I know that it's going to,
it's just going to be within
20 yards of me and it's,
and it's going to be right there and
it's stopping and it's a thousand pounds
and it's screaming
like there's nothing like that.
There's nothing like that. It's exciting.
Especially that clue. It's like, ah,
shit in,
they feel like they're just going to seem
like they just look right through it.
Yeah. Oh yeah. Well they're just
so big. Yeah. They're so big.
Especially sit where you're sitting
on the ground. We were standing,
I was standing, I was right.
We were, there's this, uh,
two trees together and, uh,
there was like a little gap between,
and we could see the elk coming up the
hill and we're like looking at him coming
and he was coming in hot, coming in, hot,
pissing all over himself. And, and just,
there was, there was a, um, it was,
we got real lucky like we went out,
we're at this place called to hone ranch.
And, uh, when we went out on this trail,
we got to this place where these elk
were fighting and they had just a couple
males that got together and they were
like, fuck you. No, fuck you crash.
And which was like some
Jurassic Park Shit.
Cause if even if you have
no desire to hunt folks,
I just encourage you around September,
find somewhere,
whether it's Colorado
or Utah or California,
anywhere where there's elk are and just
have someone take you out near them and
just listen. It's so cool. The
coolest sounds, they get a grip.
I mean they're very vocal. Very
aggressive. Yeah. That's cool.
We'll do it just sounds that they make,
if you've never heard them before.
Hi
Dude. That's pretty good. I recorded
them. I got a hold on a second.
Let me see how I can find it here.
I've got a video where I recorded it.
See if I get some of them when you
can hear it. The cows are cool.
I mean the cows even make
a weird high pitched. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. That's weird too.
Like they're communicating
with each other. It's a very,
it's a very strange animal man here.
Like I play this,
so that's the,
that's the
call.
Yeah.
That's my friend Brian who's making
the noise and he's trying to pull them
closer to us. But you hear them off in
the distance. They stay, they stuck.
That's it.
But that thing that you hear in the
background screaming at each other. Yeah.
Yeah.
That was the loud ones.
Fake. This one's real. Yeah.
I don't know where my best
one is, but they, they make
some weird, those red deer,
which are fairly related to jell. Very
similar. Do they roar instead of bugle?
Yeah. They sound like
lions. Yeah. They sound like
they look like something not a Dr
Seuss to, yeah. They don't look real.
Like stags don't look real.
They don't,
especially like Caribou don't
look really either. Yeah. Their,
their antlers are way too big for
their head. That looks stupid. Yeah.
I took my dad Caribou hunting this year.
That was really fun.
But any shot of big Caribou and it's
like the horn, the allergies themselves.
That's the hardest part to carry out cause
it's just cumbersome. Yeah, of course.
Awesome trees growing out
of an animal's head. Well,
between them and Moose and elk,
it's like how did this happen where they
evolved uniformly to have these like
super similar bizarre tree light growth
growing out of their head that they only
use when they're fucking, yeah. And then
they look on fucking, they lose them,
just gone. And then they grow them
back. Well, we found a Brian, my,
a friend from to home ranch found a, a
dead elk that got stabbed by another elk.
They were duking it out and one of them
just ran the other one through with his
antlers and killed him.
And he was a big elk too.
Like a big six by six huge thousand pound
dead elk with holes in his body from,
yeah, that'll happen. I've seen
like will at least read your,
but when they fight
and then the third one,
when they get in a fight with three and
the one just kind of side punches him
while they're fighting and sucker punches
him. Yeah. It's always that bitch. Yeah.
He's not even in an involved in the
fight. He's not even, he's like running.
It's just so crazy that this has been
going on like this for thousands of years.
That's how they do it.
They grow trees out of their head.
They smashed into each other and the
girl's like, all right, you can fuck me.
I liked,
I liked the way you tree fight for the
elk are probably looking at us going like,
look, they're in, dudes are
in the belly shirts now.
And you're like,
oh,
he's got the best metal box that he
drives around now. He gets to fuck. Yeah,
yeah. This is all, it's all nature
itself. I mean the octopus, I mean it's,
it's way weirder. The name thing
you'll ever see in the, yeah.
In the world of the ground, you know,
the, the, the land world, that's,
that's more bizarre than anything
I think I've ever seen in my life.
The ocean is really our, our largest
wilderness. I mean, it's huge.
I think there's a lot we don't know
about it. There's some crazy stuff.
I think most of the stuff, if it wasn't,
that's the thing that I think about,
like the crack and it's this legend door
lochness monster big foot or whatever.
And then once we identify
it, oh, it's, it's just an
octopus. You know what I mean?
If, if we didn't know octopus
existed and we were like,
there's this animal in the ocean that
shaped shifts and changes colors and inks
and can look like other animals is really
smart and we give it some crazy name,
you know, and then, and then we
find it and it's just normal.
So once we identify it
and it's a real thing,
it becomes boring as an octopus.
Is that,
what does that we have a weird desire
to only chase the unknown. I don't know.
That's a strange thing
when it comes to nature,
like the discovery of new species is,
it's a precedent above all.
Like they've found a new frog,
but at the end of the day,
it's just a fucking just frog.
But even if it does
the most amazing thing,
we've never seen the
frog did the same thing.
The octopus has changes its
shape and color and everything.
After about a week you're like, oh,
it's a frog. That changes color. Cool.
What's neck? Oh, there's probably
a monkey man out there. Yeah.
If we found big foot, that's what it would
be. Yeah. We actually found big foot.
It would be pretty cool,
but we would just open a big foot world
right next to seaworld and that would be
the over it. You'd be
like, oh well it's just a,
it's just a hairy monkey and
then we find out he's stupid.
He's not even as cool as the orcas and
he doesn't even like Jack Link's beef
jerky. Yeah, I think. And
he hates John Lithgow.
He sees John Lithgow. He
starts screaming bullshit.
Yeah.
That is the one disappointing thing
about my friend less drought is that he's
still looking for bigfoot doing
that survivor man bigfoot show.
I don't know. He believes in
it man. Oh I'd love that guy.
But the guy he goes with though,
I think it's a crazy fucking
total bullshit artists. I got,
I got approached by dude and I was at
some show somewhere at doing like a trade
show type thing.
Guys like talking to me like all serious
about how he goes and he had a business
card too, which makes it real. He's like,
I'm a squash chunter and he's talking
about the family groups and he knows their
intricacies and you can show me,
and he wants me to come out there and
film it for Solo Hunt and I was like,
trying to fuck you.
Yeah. I was like, dude,
one who's crazy or you
that you either want,
you either believe this bullshit
or you're just a straight up liar.
In which case that would make me an
idiot forever going out there. Well,
there's a lot of crazy
people out there for sure,
but it's the romantic thing about big
foot. It's just so romantic to people.
I had this guy tell me that it was a
government conspiracy to hide big foot
because of the logging industry. He
goes, think about it. Think about it.
They shut down the logging
industry for a spotted owl.
What do you think they
would do if we found a giant
monkey thank about all right.
I just did.
Makes no sense.
We'll Brunello was talking about
on his podcast recently. He's like,
where's the scat? Where's the shit?
Where's the, where's the droppings?
Like big foot would drop giant logs,
you'd find it. My thought is if I,
I'm out in some wild places a lot.
If I ever saw a big foot,
like I don't even know if I would care
that much to tell him. I'd be like, oh,
okay. That was cool. You know, because
you just be the crazy guy. Do you want,
do you want to be that guy? I don't. I'm
like, okay, well it's there. Whatever.
I guess who cares? Yeah. You might
want to just keep it to yourself.
Even if you told your friends from like
around, he's losing it fell on his head.
What we think as he probably like fell
on his head while he's maybe a coconut,
maybe got jacked by a
coconut wise out elk hunting.
I like my favorite is of the people
that they, there's just like walking.
I thought I saw something over there,
but then it wasn't there,
so it was a big foot.
That's my favorite.
I tell these people I was alone once
and I thought I saw a wolf for only two
seconds. It was a squirrel. Yeah. Was
this squirrel? I thought it was a wolf.
People driving down the road, when you
see it like a house cat and an open field,
it looks like a Black Panther even know
that happens all the time. At the time.
Lack of perspective in the distance. It
looks huge. I was talking to, they got,
when we did the bear episode,
the biologist, it was like, yeah,
to be honest we don't,
most of my work is just people calling
saying they see panthers and mountain
wines. They're just turned out
to be house cats. He's like,
that's the majority of my work
that,
well they've done that in England where
they've spotted panthers in England and
they were trying to figure out what it is.
And in most stores,
most people think that it was actually
just cat's house cats. But you know,
you get a big fat house cat and it's
dark out and you're shitting your pants
cause you're alone.
Everything looks bigger.
I really did think this
fucking score was a wolf.
Felt like a horse a second or two because
I was eating out of your bird feeder.
This drink down. I gotta stop.
And with the math, we were, uh,
in Alberta and we knew that there
was wolves in the area. There's,
there's a lot of wolves in
near, in fact, they started a,
they hunt them quite a bit up
there now, um, because they're,
they're having a lot of problems with
them because they can't figure out what
the real numbers are there.
Grizzly problems or even bigger in Alberta
because they don't have a season on
grizzlies.
And Grizzlies aren't scared of people at
all because there's no season on them.
They're not, they just don't give a
fuck. They just come towards people and,
and they,
they believe it's going to take like a
couple of tragedies before they open up a
season on them. Yeah. But he
been to Alberta, I'm sure.
I usually haven't. Yeah,
I haven't. No, I want to, well,
it's like any super dense wilderness
where good luck trying to count what the
fuck's in there.
You have no clue.
I don't even know how you're doing
your hair traps, your DNA samples.
But before that, yeah, it's weird.
Even if they do that, I mean,
how can they have enough
traps that you're looking at?
I have some video us driving
to uh, one of the locations
we went to and it's insane.
Like you were coming over this crest and
everywhere to the left and everywhere
to the right is just dense forest with
no fucking people anywhere there and a
shit load of bears and a Shitload,
a moose and a shitload of elk and they
just don't know. They just don't know.
The only way they know is by hunters
with camera traps and the catch 22 is the
hunters don't want to
report the grizzlies.
Cause if their report the grizzlies and
they shut down the black bear hunting
because right now grizzlies are
endangered or I should say protected.
They're not in danger. They see them
every day. They're sitting there,
literally they're shutting
down. They have, um, um,
like a lot of people don't
like the idea of baiting.
They don't like the idea of leaving out
food and Rinella explained like his own
distaste for it the last time he was here.
I totally get it.
But if you want to hunt bears in Alberta,
you have two choices.
You either can't hunt them in the spring
because you'll never find them or you
hunt them in the fall when they're eating
berries on hills and you'd get fined
them there. You can spot and
stalk and shoot him there.
But if you want to shoot him,
other than that, you have to bait.
And so they bait and they set up these
bait stations and they get these bears
accustomed to coming in to these
one areas to get food. Well,
they shutting them down all the time,
cause grizzlies come in and my friend
John Rivet, who is up there says duty,
you don't even want to see them
when they come in. He goes,
because you're looking at
black bears and black bears,
you know the big ones like 500 pounds.
And then also in this fucking boss comes
in through the woods and they come in
totally different. They're not quiet,
they're not trying to sneak around,
own the place, snap and twigs and common
in like a school bus. And he goes,
and then when you see them, you're like,
what the fuck? They're just so big.
Just a big monster brown bear that just
scares everything away and you got to
shut the bait down and get out of there.
So they shut the baits
down and then some of them,
they'll take carcasses from
the black bears. You know,
after they take the meat off of it,
they take what's left and they'll throw
them in the areas where the grizzlies
are just to try to
maintain them in that area.
Try to habituate them to that one area.
But even that, good luck, he's like,
there's a lot of them. They
didn't, didn't really don't know.
They don't know how many.
So there was a study recently that came
out that I tweeted that was showing how
ma there, there's way more grizzlies
up there than they thought ever.
Yeah, that's the grizzlies are one of
those things where they're kind of,
their overall range has diminished, but
the places they are, they're over poppy.
I would maybe not go as
far as overpopulation, but
they're getting there. Yeah,
they're pretty brazen. Like, I've
got a lot, I know a lot of people,
they used to hunt certain areas and
they say the grizzlies had gotten so bad
that they just don't want them anymore.
And a lot of that I just take with a
grain of salt because I think some people
just get overly spooked
about things like that. Um,
but these are people that I trust and
believe that they know what they're doing
there.
Well there's also that
weird thing that happens when grizzlies
get used to being around people and when
people are shooting elk or deer and they
hear a gunshot and they think it's a
dinner bell, when they come running
towards where the gunshot was,
cause they know there's going to be a
gut pile that gets spooky because bears
are really habitual.
Like that's why they have to,
they have to capture them or kill
them when they catch a meeting,
people's garbage. Because once they
find garbage, like that's their spot.
You're just going to keep coming back.
I was doing this,
uh,
this film project thing in Alaska and
I tracked down this guy that killed the
Kodiak bear with a knife.
Buck knife. What? Yeah,
it was crazy story old older guy too.
His name was Jeanne Moe.
There's been a ton of articles are
written about it and like outdoor life.
And if this was back,
it wasn't that long ago,
but I can't really put the
knife in a musket and show.
So I mean you're like these bear stories
and us just like I'm to tracking down
some of these barriers in this is
dark and so he's on Kodiak island.
Kodiak Brown bears are the biggest
barriers in the world, but they don't,
there's not that many attacks surprisingly
for the size of the bear and the many
there are. But there's probably
also, there's also not,
Kodiak island isn't like Yellowstone park.
I mean you didn't have that
many people there are really.
So he's getting out of deer turns
around the Baird's just on him.
All he has is the knife.
So he's like trying to fight it off,
stabbing the thing and the bear like
territory toward piece out of his arm,
out of his leg, picks him
up, the shaking him around.
Then the bear goes off and at one point
he's just like, thought he was done.
He was like yelling at the bear.
Bear comes back mauls him another time
he stabbing and fighting it off and then
I guess he stabbed it enough times.
He kept like trying to feed his arm
while he just like he said he was out of
strength. I think the bear when
officer like laid down is bleeding out.
He might have crawled to his
rifle at that point. I think he,
I can't remember if the
bear was dead or not,
but he shot at after the bear was
just like laying there and then hikes,
you know, free four miles back
to the beach and he's like,
I can't remember how old he was.
He had 60 something like that.
I remember this story. Yeah,
he was a, and then he says,
so then his son, they meet his
son, they take them to this.
There's one cabin there where
there's year round residents and uh,
it was actually on I think raspberry
island there and they bring him into this
cabin. There's a German couple that
lives there. And like he said, they,
they brought him in the cabin and for some
reason, I cannot remember exactly why,
but the dude that owned the cabin ended
up taking a chainsaw and cutting out the
wall so the rescuers could
come in and get a stretcher in,
like stabilize him cause he's just
dying on the table and they take him to
Kodiak hospital, do all the surgeries,
skin grafts, everything saved.
His life ended up getting,
keeping like you end up buying the
bare back at an auction and uh,
they may like a rug thing. So, so
I give him the bear. No, because,
well in Alaska,
if you kill a without the proper tag,
it's your responsibility to skin
it out and like bring it in. So,
so son went back while he's in the
hospital because you have to do it.
So his son went back, skin the bear out,
turned it over to the Alaska Department.
Um, and then, then they like auction
that stuff off or whatever. That's rude.
But he ended up with the bear and so it
was kind of cool to see like you saw the
bear and he saw the buck knife and
there's still like the bear's hair in the
buck knife now he's got it right
next to it on the wall. This guy,
it was a cool experience.
It was cool. It was,
it was a cool experience
hearing the story firsthand.
It was a pretty intense
stories. He was telling it.
Yeah. I just want only imagine.
It was cool. That's crazy. And then
a cooler if we didn't shoot it. Yeah.
That's buck knife to yeah.
And that's what I think. Uh,
but I mean he did fend it off with
the knife. Yeah, I guess. Well,
it's amazing that didn't get his head.
He must have been really smart with
his arms and his legs to kicking in.
Oh. If she can Christ God, this is when,
when you see the head,
like a,
I've only seen a grizzly bear
had a few times, but when you a,
I've never seen one of them in the,
in the wild separate when I was a
kid once I saw one in Yellowstone,
but they would come up to
people's car doors back then.
People would feed them at Yellowstone
from cars. They still like, Oh yeah,
remember that? Yeah, here's the scene.
They would feed them and they will allow
that for some strange reason. But uh,
I've seen skulls before and when you see
a skull and it's this wide, it's crazy.
Now when you think
about that and it's the,
the mass of the thing when you're just
a giant eating machine and an enormous
crushing eating machine.
Oh yeah.
The thing that I always remember when I
think about a grizzly bears is there's
this video of a bear chasing a moose and
a chases the moose down tackles it and
just starts eating it gut first.
And this moves is trying to get away.
And this is grizzlies.
Just eating its guts just decides,
just hold it down and start eating, you
know, that doesn't even bother telling it.
And it's like,
I got you.
Yeah. Your mind. Well, the grizzly does
it. Hey, the grizzlies not sad for it.
And he's like, he's
stoked. Yeah, he's fine.
He has pumped, but it's just the
brutality of what he's doing. You know,
the holding this thing down, you've
seen that video where the, uh, the,
the grizzly is killing a
deer in this guy's yard.
The deer screaming. I want it. Can you
play it? Yeah. Pull it, pull it up. Jamie.
Um, deer in backyard, uh,
and it's a brown brown bears
got him and screaming just
bears on its back and just,
just fucking mall and it in this guy's
yard and the guys looking out the back
window like, oh, fuck
the bear's thinking, why'd
you put a yard? Yeah, exactly.
What this is it, right? Yeah.
Hmm.
Wow.
That's intense.
Yeah.
And the people that are just listening
to this, the bears on top of it,
just jack and it's back and
it's neck and it's screaming.
And the kids are standing right there.
So many standing right there.
Oh my God.
Mule deer.
Yeah.
It's pretty big deer too. Yeah,
and then not a big bear. No.
Mary's, it'd be a color phase,
right? Yeah, it is. It's
a, it's a black bear then.
It's a blackberry at blackberry. Not all
black bears are black. Yeah. Color phase.
Black bear for po. People listen and they
can get like blonde, even blonde red.
Oh my God. It's that bear
attacking that chick. Oh, is that?
That's a dummy that was in the zoo.
That's a lady that climbed over the fence.
The pick your berries or friends. Don't
make me watch this. Shut this off.
Can I just can't.
I can't.
Have you ever been in a situation where
you felt like vulnerable to a animals?
No. No I haven't. I mean
I've seen animals be semi
aggressive, but no, nothing.
That's a real serious.
Have you been in areas that have
large wolf populations have? Yeah,
like reintroduced wolves.
Yeah.
Have you noticed a difference between
when they were before how they are now?
Yeah.
Well now things are changing because
there's a season for him and everything,
like their manage now
and their own places, right?
Yeah. Not In Wyoming, right?
Well it still doesn't have a civil war.
I do think, and maybe it's not
anymore what they did for awhile. Um,
I don't know what they keep changing
it back and forth. But uh, yeah,
I mean there's definitely in one of the
areas that I grew up hunting and guiding
and all that stuff, you have the wolf,
the wolf population exploded in there,
but also the elk population exploded
after fire because there's a huge dynamic
between forest fires and elk
because this new growth, new growth,
they need that new growth.
So one of the things like one of
the things that really hinders,
and that's another thing,
it comes back to like humans
regulating too much is we stopped,
we like do fire prevention and try to
prevent forest fires when huge forest
fires increase populations.
So there's a huge ebb and flow.
And when we hinder that
and try not to have fires,
animal populations decline actually.
So that's a huge thing too.
That's a whole nother topic.
Well,
it's the micromanaging of some incredibly
complex systems that we don't totally
understand like forest fires or like
predators, like we've tried to, you know,
keep predators away from certain types of
prey to allow these animals to survive.
And the way,
the weird thing about it is when you
really look at the overall population of
animals on this planet,
the that have ever existed,
90 something percent of everything
that's ever existed as extinct. Yeah.
And it can teach. It probably will
continue to be that way, I would imagine.
Unless we keep fucking with it.
Certain animals,
there's some animals that will probably
just go extinct and yeah, maybe.
Maybe humans had a huge part to do
with it and maybe others, you know,
I don't know. If we did, maybe they
would have gone extinct anyways.
I feel like the rhinos
probably on the brink now. It's
pretty close. Yeah, there's,
yeah. Sad. It's too bad. It's such a cool
animal. And there's soap prehistoric.
Apparently they move incredibly fast.
Yeah.
Like that's such a wild animal.
And you look at it like that.
Might as well be a stegosaurus.
Like what is the difference between that,
you know, had a triceratops, not
much. Not much. Yeah. I mean some,
some different variations in
the horns. They try. Yeah.
Triceratops was a cold blooded
animal. Right. But were
some of the dinosaurs? Boy,
I want to say a few of them were warm
blooded. Like some of the beings,
enormous creatures that lived during
that time were warm blooded was,
I think that's a more recent debate.
Yeah.
But on the wolves, yeah, they've
definitely been reintroduced areas,
affected populations and then the
wolf populations then explode up.
Populations explode,
wolf population explodes.
Elk population drops with
populations remains large.
And you would,
you would almost think,
well over time the wolves
would start to die off,
but they can also just
become more nomadic,
kill off an area and then just move on.
Yeah. You know, they're fucking smart too.
Yeah. You did that wolf episode. That
was really cool. Cause you know the, the,
when you mimic the tactics
that they use of a,
of chasing animals into like traps.
Yep.
They set traps for elk.
Yeah. They would. Well,
wolf hunts animals by chasing.
So if it an l stands its ground,
the wolves generally won't go in and
kill it because they stand the risk of
being injured.
So they incite it to run and as they get
it on the run then they can get it from
the back end, slow it down and
kill it. And that's, that's
how they hunt. And Yeah.
So that was in that episode meeting.
My brother tried to do the same thing,
run the elk,
catch up and cut them off
and hunt like the wolf.
I mean they have a lot of,
well they've got a lot better stamina
than us and there are just far superior at
doing it. But humans are pretty
good at doing it as well,
which is pretty impressive. Well
that's a big thing in Africa, right?
They can do their assistance
assistance all. Yeah.
And the other thing about elk is how
quick they can move up the side of a
mountain. Yeah. But they tire out
fast today. Yeah. If you chase that,
you'll see their tongues are hanging
out there. Big, large animal. Like,
even you think of a horse and if you,
if you push a horse up a mountain,
you can walk up a mountain faster than
a horse over a long period of time.
Really? Yeah. Especially in the heat. They
just start to overheat. Whereas we sweat,
we carry water and they're just like,
I would've never imagined that because
when I see people packing out with horses,
I'd be like, well that's because
the horse don't get tired.
They do get tired and they, I mean,
they sweat still the sweat, but um,
they uh, yeah, they,
well a horse can carry a lot more weight
than us and it's not on your back.
The horse isn't complaining that state.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. This is fun.
I like fucking tired, man. I just don't
know how to say cut the shit. Yeah.
He's like, he just tries. Next time you go
to round them up to pack, he's like, man,
he's a little hard to get to the corral.
Do they, do they get sore too? They must.
Oh yeah. They get sore and they sweat and
you just don't push him either. Right.
Like he take it slow and walk and yeah,
we're about out of time.
Is there anything else you want
to add or let people know? A,
there's another way to
get your show right.
It's not just a watch it on television
and if they have that Verizon fios
problem, if you've got the horizon fire
problem or you want maybe saw an episode,
missed an episode, you want it, I
know where you can get it and do it.
Yeah, it's a Apex
predator.tv. Okay. Pittsburgh.
And so you can download it. You can
buy the season or just single episodes.
And last time I was on your podcast there
I had a promo code and forgot to give
it out and there were seven people who
were in genius enough to type in Rogan
and they got a huge deal. So there
are seven get it out. Yeah, there,
there are just people that listen to your,
there's seven of them.
They'll listen to your podcast and when
they go to buy stuff they type in your
name and it gets some sweet deals.
So your name, you just type in Rogan.
There is a, there's like a
promo code. Oh, that's cool.
Because we use that code for
so many different sponsors.
So you can use Rogan or jre. Oh,
beautiful. And I would need to,
I think it's like, it's a, it's a sweet
discount. That's a cool a website too.
Who did your website? Uh, we ate Zpz
Dana, what the fuck they're doing?
That's bad ass. There's a,
that's, that's the intro.
It's very cool background.
Very cool. And a solo hunter.
You're on some of those episodes.
Tim Burnett is on the other ones and
that's on the outdoor channel as well.
And we can, we've got those on VHX
now too. Oh, are they really? Okay.
I don't know if, yeah, there's
no promo codes. Okay. And
there are free on youtube,
so yeah. Then those are great too.
All right. Remy Warren. Thanks a lot.
Thank you very much. Up on
brother. Yeah. All right folks.
We'll be back tomorrow with
Daniele Bolelli so we'll see.
Then much love. So, yeah.
Yeah.